Two
Joel,
listen,
Ladies and gentlemen,
Joe List.
Oh,
I'm already in.
I'm already going to do it like when the morning Dj guys,
I appreciate it.
Joe.
I hear you're in town for the funny fuck
I am.
I'm doing the funny fuck this weekend.
Tonight through Sunday.
Excellent.
Actually,
you are working with me tonight.
We have two sold out shows at the Hollywood improv.
I appreciate it.
I'm excited to share.
It's going to be fun.
It's going to be the machine.
Bert Kreischer,
love bird and cheeto.
Santino Andrew Santina.
Do you know Andrew?
I know,
I know Andrew.
I don't know if I don't know him personally.
You just know he's hilarious.
Yeah.
She'd be a good old fucking time.
I'm excited.
Sites for having my pleasure.
My pleasure.
How long have you down for?
I leave tomorrow morning.
Ah,
here on Sunday.
I got here Saturday actually,
but I stayed down in Manhattan beach.
Oh,
what are you doing?
Posh.
Hanging out with the people by the beach.
It was night while was down in the airport.
My wife is here and I said,
let's go down to Manhattan beach for lunch.
And we were enjoying ourselves.
So we got a hotel and made love and walked on the beach.
Oh,
you made love.
Yeah.
I just really love her.
If you meet love,
I do.
Ooh.
I went to a party once in Manhattan beach and the guy collected toasters.
Oh.
And I was like,
what is this?
And he's like,
ah,
I just collect toasters.
I'm like,
okay.
From all different time periods.
Like he had a toaster from like the 50s with all this Patina on it.
And then you had modern toasters.
But he,
I think he was trying too hard.
You know,
there's some dudes just where bowling shoes and shit,
they just try too hard to be whacking.
Yeah.
Was he like a hipster or was there like an old is a girl.
He was a guy who was trying to fuck my girlfriend.
Oh.
And she wanted to go to this party.
So looking.
All right.
Wow.
I think she was an actress and I think he was in the movie business.
Imagine getting cucked by a toaster pleasure.
Yeah,
almost it,
well it wasn't,
it was one of them squirrely deals where she was like,
I'm so not interested in him.
I just want to go to this party for network thing.
I was a young lad.
I had just moved to Hollywood and did not know the ways okay.
Of this goofy fucking town yet.
I hadn't,
uh,
I hadn't exercised myself from Hollywood,
you know,
I was still doing the thing,
acting,
going on auditions and shit.
So it was like you,
when you first get here you're like,
what is this?
Especially in the 90s,
it was super squirrely cause everybody was trying to get a development deal and
everybody was trying to get a sitcom and they kind of like let you think that
that was the only way you have to get a sitcom.
I want to be like Roseann do you want to be like Tim Allen?
What about Seinfeld?
He got a sitcom.
You should get a sitcom.
Like damn,
I want to get a of,
and so everybody was out here just trying to do the acting thing.
I did it for awhile and after awhile you're like,
these people are not worth it.
But you did get a sitcom,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
I've got a couple of them and I was on a couple of them.
It seems like fun.
Um,
it's fun.
Stand ups.
More fun.
Yeah.
It's not something I'd be interested in doing,
but
if you could do a sitcom with all stand ups,
that would be the shit that would be the shit.
Like if you,
you could do a sitcom with really good writers who were cool and all the people
the show were standups
that would be fucking monstrous.
But it's not usually like that.
No.
And it seems very,
uh,
what do you call it?
Uh,
corporate and you're going to do this and this and a lot of rules and stuff.
It seems like podcasts,
they're trying to make money,
you know,
and they can't make money if,
uh,
people do things and get people in trouble.
They say things and get people angry or someone calls up human resources and Joe
Lewis was talking about his deck.
Yeah.
The craft service lady heard it.
And now there's a lawsuit,
I think with podcasts.
Now,
most of us comedians with podcasts have no chance of getting any corporate job.
I don't think that's true.
Really.
I get offered shit all the time.
I think that we don't need it though,
right?
I think it's,
it actually will get in the way.
Have you ever written on a Sitcom?
No.
Written on anything.
When you,
when you write,
there's a trap that
comics falling into that are good writers.
They,
they get the Sitcom writing gig and it's a sweet gig.
You get paid thousands of dollars a week,
your bills,
your bills are covered so you feel good,
but you're never going on the road.
You're,
you're in town all the time.
He just doing sets around town.
So you're pretending that you're still comic,
but you're really a sitcom writer who kind of like has a hobby you're doing
stand up and you never develop on the road.
And there's a bunch of guys.
Do you know Owen Smith?
Uh,
I,
that's another guy.
I don't know.
I've met him a couple of times.
Walk in hilarious.
One of the best comics
in the world and he's just been spending so many years doing the sitcoms.
Like I saw him one night at the comedy store.
I'm like,
how the fuck is this guy?
Not Gigantic.
Like how does he not have a Netflix hour that everyone's talking about?
How has it everybody not trying to book in places,
it's just because he's been doing this,
this Sitcom writer thing.
He's trying to break out of that now though.
Tommy John Again is another guy.
You know Tommy John Again,
I've heard of him.
He's one of the best comedians I think there is.
He's a writer.
He's been writing on a TV show,
but he's happy.
He likes,
he's got two kids and it keeps them off the road.
But to me it's a bummer as a comedy fan cause I'm like,
ah,
I want to see new hour.
But he's still,
I think he's still works a little bit.
Yeah.
Mitch Hedberg had a really funny bit about that,
about how comedy,
like when you're a comedian,
it's the only job where someone asks you to do another job.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There was somebody,
when I first moved to New York,
there was a guy that was like,
do you do any writing?
And I was like,
well I did all that.
Right.
I wrote all that.
But I,
that's why I never liked writing other than standup because standup,
I can write all day and then go do it that night.
Whereas when I'm writing like a movie or a TV show,
I'm like,
I'm wasting my,
this isn't going to get made.
It's just not,
my therapist says that's not the way,
that's not what should inspire you to write.
You should be ready.
Cause it's a way to express yourself.
You therapist is right.
But then again,
if you are writing something and nothing happens,
this is fucking stupid.
It feels,
it feels wasteful.
But I could be writing jokes that I do on stage.
Yeah.
You,
um,
you just get into that sort of
Dang where you're just like,
what am I doing here?
And then it steals your thunder.
Yeah.
I feel that way all the time.
Unrelated.
Yeah.
What am I doing?
Here you are right,
right.
You sit down and write a little
bit?
Yeah,
I try to,
but a lot of times,
um,
a lot of times I'll start writing and then I ended up just jerking off.
Jerking off.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Although I do that less than I used.
Louie said that he had,
he kept his,
uh,
he had one laptop that could not connect to the Internet.
He had it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He still does that.
But if you do that,
like what if you want to Google something while you're writing?
Well,
I do that a lot and I'll use it as an excuse.
I'll be writing and then I'm like,
what?
What's the origin?
Let me Google that for research and then before,
you know what I'm just going through Instagram and I'm jerking off.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
You got to have discipline.
That's all.
I give myself an hour.
I have one hour than a half to write and then if I enjoy it,
I keep going.
But one for one hour,
there is nothing going on.
But writing,
she,
that's ambitious.
I have to go literally,
I'm not even joking like 10 minutes.
Let me do 10 minutes and usually they'll go a little longer cause I'm like,
all right,
now I'll do like 30 minutes.
Then I'm like,
then you can treat yourself.
I'm a child.
I am too.
But I found that,
I mean obviously we came in here,
we were,
me and Jeff were embroiled in a quick death match.
Yeah.
And we wouldn't stop to say hi.
I said hi briefly.
I appreciate,
I felt bad.
I felt like I walked in and you fucking you a little bit like,
well I got here early and I was going to,
I'm always compulsively early everywhere.
I spend a lot of time just doing laps around places cause I have so much
anxiety.
But I parked and I was like,
I'll just sit in my car for 10 minutes.
And then a big came out and was just looking at me.
And so then I was like,
I think at this must mean I have to get out of the car.
Yeah,
he's armed.
So I got out.
Um Oh is he?
Oh Great.
Oh I'm terrified.
But yeah,
so I got here early.
I was on camera,
but I would have showed up right at,
yeah,
it doesn't matter.
All right.
We shouldn't have snuck in that extra game.
It's just we get the problem is you,
you,
you play one game and then it gets going like we play for half hour,
plead to 100 points,
100 deaths and then it gets intense and then if one guy beats the other guy
gives him a drubbing,
then the other guy wants revenge and then you have to play that second,
right?
Yeah.
It's addictive and you start off your day with two ass kickings.
It's like trick enough,
a hundred deaths.
You start off your day with to jerk off sessions.
You're like,
man,
I have a lot of catching up to do a phone and make this a productive day.
I use still jerking off a lot.
Of course I feel like I know jerk off that much in the last,
well I have a wife and we have sex,
but here when she's not,
when she's away then you jerk off.
I'll drop off a little bit though.
I have less,
uh,
less than I used to.
There's something wrong with me.
I can still get my a vagina hard.
I just,
I'm just not a,
I'm not as interested.
Nothing wrong with that man.
But when she,
when I'm with her,
I'm very interested.
Yeah.
Yes,
yes.
I get it.
But in your free time,
you've got other shit on your mind.
Yes.
You're focused.
I am focused on about 5,000 things at once.
Yeah,
me too.
World,
the peanut comedian.
That's a lot.
Yeah.
It's Louis' idea is a good idea on paper to like not,
not have anything connected to the Internet.
Well he is just,
I think about doing this now he has two phones,
like a flip phone that like 12 people have the number and then he looks like a
smartphone that he'll leave behind.
So like his kids can call them or as you know mother or whatever.
Uh,
I'm one of the 12th but like you,
someone can get in touch with him and you can call nine one,
one word,
but there is no Twitter or Instagram,
whatever.
So that's like a decent ideas to phones cause I'm,
I'm fucked up with.
But then you know,
obviously you're friends with Ari.
He is the flip phone.
Louis has a flip phone.
But what sucks is when you're hanging out with these people,
they still need the shit.
So they ended up using your phone.
Exactly.
Like I'll go hiking with Ari whenever a trip and he's like,
pull up your Google maps.
Can I use your phone?
And they just has my phone.
How I have some discipline.
Ari.
Yeah.
And a real phone.
I don't want anyone to have my fight.
It's not like I don't have crazy parties or whatever.
Touching my phone.
I don't like people holding my phone.
That's like someone wearing your underwear.
Yes.
It's worse.
Can I borrow your underwear?
What you can eat.
You can take my underwear.
Raw Dog.
She just put pants on.
Yeah.
Do you have to have underwear?
It's weird.
If you don't need underwear.
You do.
I liked,
I sprinkle a lot of tinkle.
Yeah.
But um,
if you have a good pair of underwear,
it's better than like if you weren't jeans and shit.
And your ticks rubbing against your separate shit's annoying.
Yeah,
that's no good.
Good point.
You need to undo it.
I take it back.
I want to,
I want to stop and walk back.
My endless need.
Some discipline just needs some goddamn discipline.
He's such a child.
He does,
but I understand the addiction and stuff.
It's difficult because I have it where I'm like,
just don't look.
Yeah,
but I'm,
I'm obsessed with my phone too.
I am too,
but I'm not as bad as I used to be.
But Ari,
uh,
he realizes it.
He's like,
yeah,
he's not a loser.
He's a winner.
Like you figure shit out.
He's like,
all right,
I have a fucking problem and I'm not getting better at this so I'm just going to
get rid of it.
Yeah.
Can get this fucking stupid flip phone that I could barely text on.
Like whenever he texts me,
it's like a miracle.
I'm like,
what are you doing here with this caveman phone?
Yeah,
the text message from the stupid fucking phone and then you have to keep it
short because you can't send like a long thing because it comes in like three
pages and out of order.
So it's like anyways,
I'm gay now.
And then it's like,
hey,
I just met.
It's all fucked up.
Yeah,
it sucks.
Button beBee.
I'm thinking about doing it myself.
Well to getting crazier now they're having these folding phones that get the
blow out to like 10 inches of you seen these goddamn things.
Oh well Samsung released it but then they took it back cause it started
breaking.
But it's uh,
it's a,
it looks like a regular smart phone,
but it's fat and the reason why it's fat as you can open it up and it becomes a
giant smartphone.
Oh that seems kind of Nice.
It's pretty nice if you need an iPad every where you go.
Right.
But do you know,
I use my phone also.
I was like a compute.
I barely use my computer.
I just write emails and Shit on my phone.
Yeah.
I write very few emails on my phone.
I tried.
I'm trying to limit my hour on the phone to to one hour,
one
hour for the whole day.
One hour of screen time.
Yeah,
that's a,
it's doable.
Pressive yeah,
well I,
I forced it on my kid so I'm like,
okay,
if she gets an hour of screen time,
I should get an hour of screen time.
Right,
but you're also running a business.
You have a team,
but I'm also responsible.
Right?
Yeah.
I have other people that pick up the slack.
It's a full on addiction though.
It's fucked up.
Like I will,
I'll go on a play,
I'll fly across the country.
I'm on airplane mode if you can't even use it and I'll find myself just looking
at photos just because I want the dopamine.
Where the fuck it is of just holding and moving my phone.
Yeah.
It's really a
a problem.
It is a problem and I'm actually,
I've been doing a bit about it,
about the real problem is what's next?
The real problem is where does it go from here because it's got you hooked.
Just looking at
photos and texts.
Well,
I mean,
I walked in,
you couldn't say hello and you are crying playing quake.
So that might be the next step.
Just something about staring at that screen.
When you get really intense,
your eyes start watering.
I swear to God I wasn't emotional.
No,
I thought your parents passed away.
As I pulled in,
all these guys leave here.
I feel like a freak,
first of all.
Sometimes we leave.
Well,
we'll have these battles that'll go like two hours.
And then when,
when I leave my fucking hearts pounding,
my adrenaline's rushing and I'm like,
see you later man.
Bye.
Wow.
Can we leave?
And we're like,
what the fuck?
And I'm driving home.
I'll tell.
It's like literally like I just had a fight.
They go into a fight with somebody.
Wow.
I don't have that.
Yeah,
it's,
it's
[inaudible] very,
very bad addiction.
But it's really fun too.
So part of me is like,
I'm enjoying the shit out of this.
It's really fun to play.
I think that's the case.
Just enjoy it.
You got to enjoy whatever decision you're making.
This is again,
my therapist tell us three therapist tells.
Yeah.
Well I'm dealing,
I had like a horrible diet my whole life for lady.
Well now I've changed.
I'm going through a bit of a medical situation right now.
Um,
I have aids.
I came here to do the Good Jack Jones.
Yeah.
Kind of the fun,
the fun.
You lose a little weight,
whatever,
but it makes you whimsical.
Uh,
yeah.
I feel good.
I can play basketball now.
Like the Flintstones,
like gay old time today have aids.
Yeah.
That's why they're not here anymore.
Um,
uh,
what was I gonna say?
I got caught up on the flips.
Total issue.
Oh,
so I have this thing called silent reflux.
If you ever heard of this.
No.
It's acid reflux buttons.
They call it silent because there's no,
um,
heartburn.
It's different than Gerd.
It just goes straight up into your vocal chords,
into deer throats.
It's like fucking up my [inaudible] my shit.
Oh No.
And I wake up at like a cough and it's like into my,
they're calling it respiratory reflux now we're at like,
it's almost like asthma sinus shit.
And it's diet related.
Yeah.
Well,
I ate exclusively a drink coke clotting like three or four cokes a day
exclusively like a large pizza,
extra Marinara chicken parm,
extra Marinara,
chipolte lay extra hot sauce,
chocolate chip cookies.
You eat garbage like a garbage child.
I'm a garbage child.
A grown up baby.
Yeah.
So I just ate exclusively that I was in therapy and it,
but I knew I was like,
I'm getting,
I'm fucking myself up.
I'm going to die.
I'm going to get cancer and die.
And my therapist is like,
just at least except your decision.
Enjoy eating shit.
Yeah.
He's like,
you're eating shit and not even enjoying it.
So what's the point?
And he's like accepting it would actually probably help you to eat healthier.
And I was like,
good point.
I'll just start enjoying it.
And that lasted 10 days and that's when the reflux started and I had to
completely change my diet.
So I should have had that conversation 25 years earlier.
So now I just ate like shit without enjoying it.
And now I'm refluxing mm.
And I can't eat any of that.
I had to cut out everything.
So what did they tell you to eat?
Now you have to cut out dairy.
What do you,
what do you cut?
Well,
going back to the doctor on Thursday that I'm seeing a specialist who coined the
phrase,
it's like 1000 bucks for a consultation.
But at this point I'm like,
I'm losing my mind.
So crazy.
Is that the doctor can charge
$1,000 just talk to you.
Well,
the other,
the first doctor I went to as an ENT and they do a thing,
which I think is fucked up.
They're like,
I'm like,
I'm paying cash.
I don't have insurance.
I'm paying out of pocket.
And you're like,
Oh,
it's a 20% discount if you're paying out of pocket.
Like,
like I'm at a record store,
like were like,
we give you a discount if you pay a crash.
And I'm like,
all right,
that seems bizarre.
It's like my wellbeing.
That seems like something
didn't.
Someone who deals with drug dealers guys come in with bullet wounds.
You got cash and 20% off.
It's a little stretched.
Yep.
Well,
I rolled up my money and put in a rubber band around it and handed it to him.
We always like to think,
we always like to think that doctors are there.
There's something special about them.
Know they're beyond reproach there,
above and beyond.
But I was reading this book called dead doctors don't lie.
It's by this Guy Joel Wallach.
And it's all about mineral deficiencies and how many people have mineral
deficiencies and how little doctors actually know about nutrition and how,
uh,
so many doctors are not only unhealthy but have,
at least back when he wrote this book,
have easy access to prescription medicine and they're just overdosing.
Right?
They're just fucking,
yeah.
Cooking themselves a coke.
Right?
Yeah.
I'm trying to do like an organic,
he thinks I started getting all these salads and oatmeal and a salmon set
helping.
No,
I feel bad.
I've lost weight.
I'm thin.
I'm taking huge like green baby legs shits like and say like the s with the
good,
right?
Yeah.
It feels amazing flying out and I feel light and I'm,
I'm a little more defined.
That's good.
Um,
but my throat is still all fucked up,
but I've heard it takes months and I'm like,
maybe my body's repairing and it just doesn't,
it takes time to whatever.
So what specifically they tell you to get off of?
Well,
first when I first went there,
it was like the end of the day,
like I started having like a fucking panic attack cause it's like white shit
coming down my throat.
Um,
not the first time that's happened folks.
Why
come I get it.
All right.
Um,
so I went,
I just ran in there and I was like,
can I get,
I got to see a doctor today.
I'm losing my mind.
And they were like,
we can squeeze in an appointment.
And I think when you show up right before they close with no health insurance,
the guy kind of looked and went,
oh yeah,
that's silent reflux.
And then they print out a piece of paper from like Web MD,
which is amazing to me.
They just print shit out that I could have googled.
And he's like,
try to cut out the spicy foods,
take private sec and uh,
whatever.
So he made it seem like it was no big deal.
Spicy foods.
Yeah.
That's interesting that they would tell you to cut that out.
Like what,
what,
what is,
what did they say?
What is actually causing,
like what is the mechanism?
Like what's,
what's forcing this reaction?
Well,
I think what happens is,
um,
has something to do with your,
uh,
esophageal sphincter,
which is,
I didn't know I had one.
Uh,
yeah,
you do.
It's a,
I guess it's at like,
I've read so much of this shit just like you're saying that g spot when you're
sucking dicks.
Yeah.
He gets down there.
Right.
I feel like that would be deep in there.
Um,
so I,
it opens up and there's supposed to be some acid that comes up,
but I got too much acid.
I guess it flexes in the reflexes,
but my,
I think what happens is it gets so fucked up from diet that it becomes,
um,
compromise.
So it doesn't matter what I eat,
it's just open like a,
like a fucking big,
like a loose hassle.
Yeah.
So,
and that's from just all the acid hitting it over and over and over again.
Yeah.
So I got into this,
there's a woman named,
uh,
Dr. Kaufman,
I forget her first name,
but she actually is in New York.
That's what I'm going to see for 1000 bucks.
But she like coined the phrase and wrote all these books and stuff and says,
you can fix it through,
um,
diet.
But I've been taking like a ton of private second shit.
And evidently I guess a,
I don't know what's helping,
like how much worse it would be if I wasn't taking that.
But then when you get off of that,
there's a thing called rebound reflex where it just comes back fucking
gangbusters.
Oh,
no.
So,
uh,
I'm all like the people that take Xanax.
Yeah.
I used to take Xanax,
Cisco,
I've never taken him,
but they said that when you get off of it,
that you get super anxious.
Hmm.
I don't remember that.
I only took it if I was like having a panic attack or whatever,
but I took Paxil for a long time and then I couldn't come on the whoa.
Yeah.
Eventually.
It's unpleasant.
You and Mike Tyson at the same problem.
Can he not come?
Couldn't whims on the Paxil.
We're very similar guys.
Real son.
Wait a lot of comments then when your backgrounds.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I used to play with pigeons.
I shouldn't say play with.
I see you listening.
This is what's terrifying about this show.
He's a good guy.
He's super friendly.
He's like a a giant bear.
That's like your friend.
Yeah,
I'd like to,
he's like really sweet guy,
but you are very aware when you're around him that he is not you.
Like this is a cup.
This is an elite super athlete from the hall of
He's Mike motherfucking Tyson and even though he doesn't even hardly work out
anymore,
like even when you shake his hand it's like holding onto a brick.
It's like his whole body is like,
he's like five feet wide.
Yeah.
I imagine a few work,
I don't know.
You probably know more about this than I do.
If you work out enough for long enough and then you stopped,
I imagine you're going to have a base.
You definitely have a base.
Like I like when I was a kid,
when I was younger,
I ran,
I was a distance runner and I stopped running distance.
But I feel like now I could go run five miles because I used to.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
I feel similarly like Mike Tyson could feet
me up probably.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
he would kill you.
You don't pray that well it's true.
I don't know.
He might have some skills.
Um,
my friend CT Fletcher,
he actually had a heart surgery heart transplant one year ago and uh,
he hasn't been able to do much of anything other than like very light exercise.
Like he's just trying to like build his body back up.
But he's,
he used to be a world champion power lifter and even though he hasn't worked
out,
like really worked out and probably like a year and a half,
he still has giant arms.
He's still huge.
You keep a lot of it.
He could probably pick me up.
Also.
You think,
uh,
he can't move that much cause of the heart.
You know,
he's on a bunch of pills and stuff,
but if he got ahold of you,
you'd be fucked.
He's got,
his arms are like double mine to have my arms on top of it.
It's a big,
he was an enormous man at one time.
Basically my height,
maybe an inch.
He's probably like five,
nine,
maybe an inch taller than me.
And he weighed three,
what do you say?
Three 20 at one point 320 pounds.
Wow.
Is it a picture of him?
It's so ridiculous.
Like you can't believe that a human could stack that much meat onto your
skeleton.
Yeah.
I wonder that if I just started really lifting,
lifting,
cause I'm like I can't eat healthy foods.
I mean I can't eat shitty foods anymore and I don't drink and I don't do drugs.
I'm like,
maybe I could get into exercise.
Like how big can I get?
Can I get fucking,
you didn't get big.
Yeah,
you definitely get bigger.
It's,
it's you're an Ectomorph,
which become,
again,
tall and you're tall and lean and tall is one of the reasons why,
even though you are on that terrible diet and not built like a Ralphie May,
right.
Or something like that.
You know what I mean?
Like some people just have bodies that just,
they can absorb a lot of sugar and a lot of bullshit and your body,
I've obviously can do that.
Yeah.
That's CT Fletcher when he was three pounds fucking size was so ridiculous to
face.
So huge flipped the fuck.
Those are ridiculous.
Do you know,
anyway,
I remember the fight or Vinny Pazienza.
Sure.
He's from Rhode Island and I was working the providence comedy connection years
ago and he was at the show.
We kind of met and then he was,
he was drinking a little bit and then after the show we were all at the bar
and uh,
I think it was like kind of fucking around and he's like,
ah,
the comedian,
I'm gonna come over there and kick that Canadians as he was kind of like a,
I think he was fucking with me,
whatever.
But I was like terrified.
I'm a terrified human anyways.
And he's like,
yeah,
I want to come over there and beat his ass.
And then his girl that he was with was kind of like 50 no,
and she was like kind of looked nervous where I was like,
wait,
does this something,
is this like a real thing?
And like everyone there was like,
ah,
he just fucking with you.
And then I was like telling the story later to like my fat,
my uncle,
and he's like,
ah,
he's drawn you fucking,
you'll be fine.
What?
I was like,
what do you mean?
He's like,
Eh,
he's older,
he's drunk.
Oh my God.
I'm like,
at what point of me hitting Vinnie,
Patsy Enzo.
Do you think he'd be like,
all right,
I'm sorry.
I like,
this is no amount of like,
eh,
he's a little older.
He's had a couple of cocktails,
uncles or
terrible for advice,
but you're not their kid to like,
hey,
you figure it out.
They give you like really abbreviated shitty advice.
Yeah.
It's like a nice idea that I'd be like,
yeah,
you'd be able to handle that.
I'm like,
no,
no.
I think he would,
I think he would win.
He's the fucking champion of the world at beating people up.
Yeah,
he was.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
It'd be a real problem for you.
I wouldn't know how drunk he was.
Yeah.
I wouldn't have fared well.
It's uncles.
Hmm.
They,
they're terrible with advice that uncles are always buying you beer when you're
too young though,
showing you things you shouldn't see.
Yeah.
There it's fun to be one.
I'm an uncle.
Yeah,
me too.
Do you like being an,
you plan on shooting loads into the misses and having a real person?
No.
I mean,
I plan on shooting loads into our,
but I don't think so.
My wife's a comedian as well and kid,
no,
we're a little old.
I mean,
she's older.
I'm 37.
She's 41 and uh,
someone's career has to be sacrificed quite a bit,
I think to have a kid.
That's one way to look at it.
Yeah.
And not like adds up right now,
which it could change a,
anytime I'm making more money on the road.
Like,
that's the majority of our money.
So it'd have to be like,
Aye,
I've got to keep going on the road.
Right.
So,
and then we're in New York and uh,
you know,
it's hard to have it child.
Yeah.
They're very expensive as you know,
expensive in New York is a weird place to raise a child.
It's just weird.
I have friends who raise their kids in New York and they're like,
we love it.
The kids love it.
We let them go wander around the streets.
Okay.
All right.
Did they have they go to like private school and shit cause I'd be like,
no,
they go to public.
The idea of like your nine year old on the subways.
Terrified again.
Like it was anxiety,
right?
Yeah.
Every moment.
I'd be like,
my kid is getting abducted right now.
Well you never know.
Like you could get a subway where everybody's cool or you could get a subway
where there's a crazy person.
You're trapped in a tube with a crazy person.
Yeah.
It's one of the more interesting things about rolling the dice with the New York
City subways that you're,
you're just entering into a closed environment where you cannot escape for a
prolonged period of time with people that you don't know.
And most people are cool.
Yeah.
Most people just want to get to their job or their house or wherever they're
going.
But every now and then,
like I met a dude.
Do you remember there was a knife attack on a subway where a guy had killed a
couple of people and caught one guy up in the guy,
disarmed them from some moves that he learned in the ultimate fighting
championship watching it on TV?
No.
Yeah,
I met him.
He was just giant
cuts on his head.
It was really intense,
man.
Yeah,
I not,
I would not do well.
I would just be like,
yeah,
this cut me up.
I hate myself.
Well,
he's just,
when you're,
when you're in that sort of life or death situation,
it's just a,
becomes
your survival mode kicks in you like you don't even,
you didn't even know what you're doing.
Right.
I've talked to 'em people that have been attacked by animals and they say that
it's just,
you don't,
you can't even imagine how Reptilian your reaction is.
There's no rational thinking at all.
It's like 100% just a DNA firing the switches for you.
Wow.
Hmm.
I was on the,
uh,
subway a couple of years ago and I was like,
it was empty.
I was only the back of the train and there was like,
it was just me sitting there and then there was like a guy sleeping on the other
end,
like he was passed out or whatever.
And then,
uh,
there's like six hooligan,
like young teenager,
like they were acting all crazy and they got on the train on that end of the
train and they were like spitting on the guy and they were like,
well God,
there was screaming.
But the guy was like,
he was obviously drunk,
whatever.
And they were like hocking Louise on him and stuff and like jumping up and down.
And so I was just looking at my phone because it was like a,
it was a bad situation,
unpleasant.
And then they kind of turned and focus towards me and they were like,
hey,
you fucking faggot,
look up,
look up from your phone.
And then I just did into kept ignoring them and then one guy was like,
I'm going to kill you if you don't look over here.
And then the other guy was like,
I'll kill you if you keep looking at your phone.
And I was like shitting my pants.
And this is between Queensboro Plaza and Lexington Avenue,
which is a pretty long underground station.
It was like doing the thing where it's like delayed.
So it was probably like,
realistically it was like four or five minutes,
but I was like shitting my pants and there's six of them.
They were probably like early twenties late teens.
I have no fighting training or no weapon where I was like this is a bad
situation.
Like six people.
You're like,
um,
I'm not going to,
I have no six people's a problem.
Six people.
That's a problem.
I appreciate you saying it cause a lot of people are like,
I would have busted up the biggest guy or whatever the fuck.
And you're like,
dude,
tangle of arms and legs,
six people's a real problem.
The only thing that would save you though is that you're in a subway and by that
is they're not going to surround you,
right?
If you just put your back to the wall,
right.
Six people as they come towards you,
they have to kind of come towards you almost single file.
I suppose so,
yeah.
There's not a lot of room.
You can get like two at a time,
but
you could crack one
and if you crack one,
most of them will start panicking.
Most people don't know how to fight.
Right.
You smashed one guy's face and,
and he goes unconscious and then the other guys were there and you start moving
in on them.
They have this anxiety attack.
They start freaking,
unless they know how to fight and I doubt they do cause people don't have,
who know how to fight.
They don't do things like that.
It's very,
very rarely
do you run into thugs that actually know how to fight.
But that's the problem is most people know how to fight.
I'm one of those,
most
of them people.
Yeah.
So the smashing in the face.
I mean,
I can,
I know how to throw a punch,
but I'm saying even for anybody,
even for a trained fighter,
if you're in a on a subway with six guys,
it's not good.
Yeah.
Even if you really know how to fight,
if you're like a world champion,
you got to go.
God Damn it.
Because you could always break your hand.
But the first punch,
that shit happens all the time.
Yeah.
It was a unpleasant,
but after that I was like,
maybe I shouldn't get in the last train.
At least give yourself a chance to go one.
It was early.
I was on my way to this show in the city.
It was like eight o'clock,
seven 30.
But Christ,
I mean,
I don't think they were leaving draw.
I think they would just assholes.
Yeah.
Just being wild or whatever.
Wildin I think is the term.
Whether the Italian,
uh,
they were not,
they were a of Latino descent.
Yeah.
Racist.
Uh,
I am describing what I think a very PC,
uh,
no,
the way you set it,
it was clear.
You're demeaning.
I think Latino was good or is it Hispanic?
I think Hispanic is bad cause it's in reference directly to Spanish so that Tina
was better and that could be in reference to Latin America title than that.
That's all they can suck my dick.
I'm tired of it.
I really am.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
Let's see.
Knows I'm trust trying to figure out what your name is.
All right Joe.
Yeah.
But I mean,
I mean you can't just decide that something that people used forever as all of
the sudden racist.
Like here's a weird one and I don't know why this is,
you can't say Chinaman but you can say Englishman.
Hmm.
I think a lot of it has to do with,
cause uh,
the Chinese were enslaved,
does that right?
They built the railroads.
Yeah.
That's something that probably has something to do with it.
But you can say Irish men in the Irish were enslaved.
I,
there you go.
So that feats net.
Yeah.
By the way.
I'm just guessing.
This is not my Irish.
We're not enslaved here.
I mean,
there was,
some are Irish people that came over that didn't indentured servitude.
I'm sure actually now that I'm,
I am reading,
I did read something about,
uh,
Irish slaves,
but,
but in comparison to African slaves,
it's not even close.
Yeah.
I don't know much about that Irish thing,
but I know that,
um,
black people,
African American people get upset when you say,
but the Irish born slaved.
All I know is they don't like that shit.
Yeah.
They're not into that argument.
It's terrible argument.
It doesn't seem like a great one.
There's not a lot of pictures of the Irish slaves that built America.
Yeah.
I think a lot also came a voluntarily or something.
I don't,
I don't know.
Yeah.
My grandparents,
my grandfather on my father's side came from Ireland.
My,
uh,
I think my great grandparents.
Yeah.
Imagine being one of those people from the 1920s.
It's like,
fuck it.
I'm taking a chance.
I'm going to get on a fucking boat and travel across the ocean like only like 50
years after pictures were made.
Yeah.
It's insane.
I about that.
I'll tell him I watched
godfather part two the whole time.
I'm like,
yeah,
go get 'em a little buddy bucket take days.
Like the most powerful guy in the state.
Yeah,
whatever.
There's no place like that now where people just can go,
well that's here still isn't it?
But it's not though.
It's fucking hard.
Like it's hard if you're Canadian.
It's,
if you're Canadian gets hard to get over here and we're connected.
Like they make it real hard for Canadians to move here.
Yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
Well,
I know a lot of Canadian comedians and they have to like Peru.
It's the whole idea is hilarious of a comedian trying to prove they're necessary
in America is just a hoot.
Comical like this.
They're like,
can you guys write me letters that says we need more jokes in New York?
We'd need more comedians.
Always.
I think we are.
There's a finite resource of comedian.
Well,
we need more quality.
Yes.
There's plenty of comedians.
Never know.
Like I knew guys that sucked,
man for years.
And I used to have this thought,
either you're funny or you're not funny.
If you find it,
you can get funnier.
Right.
But I knew guys that used to eat shit and now they're murderers.
Keeps coming back to Ari.
Uh,
no,
no kidding.
No,
I'm zinging.
Ari was always funny.
Yeah.
He always had something like he's,
he was never as funny as he is now,
but he always had something.
It was always like,
this guy's going to make it.
Yeah.
It is interesting when people
kind of figure it out,
but I think a lot of those people,
they're trying to be what they think is supposed to be funny and eventually they
figured out to just be themselves.
And that's how it kind of,
I think you're right.
Like they're trying to do Seinfeld or something and then after awhile somebody
along the way,
it goes,
hey,
just tell the thing you said in the car.
Right,
right,
right.
I got friends like that,
that never made that flip.
Like friends from Boston,
that comics.
Yeah.
Have like the biggest disparity in funny offstage to funny on stage of anybody
where it's,
yeah,
it's puzzling.
Where I'm like,
you're the funniest person I've ever met and you've been eating shit for 20
years.
And it's like,
why?
How does that not
that used to translate?
Yes.
Interesting.
Joey Diaz is the funniest guy I've ever seen.
I've never seen anybody funnier.
And Joey Diaz,
when he first started out,
I didn't meet him when he first started out.
I met him cheese.
I probably met him four years into his career.
I met him in 95,
I think,
or [inaudible] 96,
somewhere around then.
And um,
he just couldn't figure it out on stage.
And then around [inaudible] 98,
I was,
I used to take them with me on the road around 98.
He just caught this wave and I'm Tom saying within like six months,
he went from having rough sets too.
Fucking annihilating.
Wow.
He also gained during that time at least 80 pounds.
It's just fun.
Just didn't give a fuck anymore.
Like something clicked where he didn't give a fuck anymore.
Right.
He started eating whatever he wanted to eat.
He was partying like a mad man and he would go on stage.
Just,
just didn't give a fuck.
And he was so funny.
It's like he figured out the formula leaf.
He was trying to do the actor thing.
He got sucked into that thing that we were talking about.
Where
do you want to get on sitcoms?
You want to get auditions and you're going out for movies.
And then he,
after a while he just got fucked over too many times and dealt with too many
people and he realized that he was like kind of tailoring his act for those
assholes.
Yeah.
I love those moments in any artist with the music or whatever it is.
Well,
as I know his music and comedy really.
But when they fucking finally get into that,
uh,
in the rhythm of like figuring out who they are and what they are,
and then you're like,
oh wow,
this is special to me.
It's cool to watch too,
for like
person who is trying to do it themselves because you really,
you see all the elements in the qualities that they've sort of embraced that
have helped them like the authenticity and their real thoughts and you know,
and what they,
they're there honest self deprecation and all the things that you see that just
it sort of fall into place and then you can kind of examine your own self.
Right?
Yeah.
Maybe I can,
maybe I can do that.
Well that's the thing about comedy.
I think it was like we,
we don't exist in a vacuum.
We all influenced each other sometimes too much.
Like people do the Italo voice.
Yes.
You know,
there are so many guys that do that voice.
Yes.
And it's ruthless when you see people doing it.
Like,
God,
you got to pull them aside and go,
hey man,
I'm f uh,
tell fan too,
which right.
Got Him back off the tele voice.
Yeah.
That happens.
It goes in waves too.
Remember when I was like in the early two thousands it was a lot of Dane people
were doing a lot of day and I used to say Adi was my term of another day and
impression.
There'd be all these guys that walk out and they're doing,
they're holding the mic and an impractical way.
It works for him,
but their carnival and doing weird movements and you're like,
I think that's kind of his thing.
Cute young guys and they're trying to put on baseball hats everywhere they go
and they come up with their own way to do a hand stand on the stool.
Dan got mad at a guy and wants,
cause he was wearing a Boston hat.
Oh,
interesting.
Like that's my thing.
Oh Wow.
I'm paused.
I'm wearing a Bruin shirt.
I hope that's okay.
I don't know man.
You got to check in this town so I'll send him an email.
Are you from Boston?
I'm from Whitman,
Massachusetts,
but I started there.
I was there for years.
Yeah,
I'm from Newton.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
a lot of comics from Newton.
Really?
Well,
not a lot.
John Fish.
I don't know if you know John know he's a New York guy and then Louie.
Oh,
so it's three.
Three is a lot that's come from a relatively small town.
Newton's a weird spot.
It's like a,
it's idealic if you go there right now,
it's like,
ah,
this beautiful little cute little sweet little town.
When I was growing up there just seemed like a frozen shit hole.
It was,
I think I could be wrong on this.
I think Newton was once labeled the safest town in America.
They had gone the longest distance without a murder or like a,
I think they were basic enough murder or some crap.
And then shortly after that somebody was killed.
It was like they jinxed it.
Yeah.
They probably wanted to set the record.
And this one would be the person to break it.
Yeah.
Someone's like,
fuck that.
And then they partnered.
But
it's a good place.
Yeah.
It's nice.
Uh,
Boston's a great place to grow up,
but I think it wears on you all.
My friends who live there
when I,
I still,
I still have a few buddies that lived there and I talked to him like,
man,
I don't know how many more than winters I can fucking take.
Yeah.
I guess when us,
I got a buddy that just moved to Kiwis.
He's moving to key west July 1st and he's like,
I'm tired of shoveling and it's a hard city.
People are fucking angry and the traffic and uh,
there's like an inferiority complexes.
Yeah.
It's a great place to,
I think influence you.
And then you got to get the hell out of this horrible place to date.
I never,
well,
I mean I did date there,
but was that accent,
you find a woman with that accent?
It's just,
it's a boner killer.
It's not a pleasant accident on a woman.
It's not good,
dude.
It's fun.
I hear a dude with that accent.
I said,
ah,
that'd be a good guy to drink with.
Yes.
I agree.
This most definitely a double standard that you turned down,
but as southern,
yeah,
I suppose to Texas.
Yeah.
Woo.
That's the best Australian.
I like Australia,
like an Irish,
English,
Irish,
Australian women.
I've only had sex with two Australian women in my life,
but bold stop bragging bro.
But both,
this is what's going to get worse.
Both women individually requested that I come on their face,
so I don't know if that's an Australian thing.
I'd have to call in.
If you're going to fill your woman,
have something to do with the lack of sunscreen out there.
You know,
they have a whole ozone layer.
That's true.
She's looking for a coating,
but 100% of Australian women as far as I've tested,
like enjoy it.
Yeah.
Do you think if you were a girl you'd like a guy to come in your face?
I do.
I've talked about this before.
Uh,
I think if I was a girl I would be a fucking dialed animal.
Yeah.
That'd be calm in my eyes because I'm a man and I want come on my face,
you know?
So,
yeah.
So imagine,
uh,
yeah,
I think so.
I think I'd be,
uh,
just,
just running around.
Yeah.
So I can put it up all the Dixon Buddy.
Some something.
Yeah,
some kind of disease and I've got stuff to give them to do.
You've got a bunch of them.
I had HPV that goes away.
I got married.
HPV goes away.
No,
you still have,
does he shoot a dirty load in someone?
You can give it to him still.
Well I think,
I believe I could be.
I put could.
I got bad info from my ENT,
but I'm pretty sure you did.
I had pretty sure you keep that shit.
Can we look this up over here?
I think HPV does go away if you stop having sexual intercourse with different
people,
but I think it goes away for you.
But I think it's still in your blood and I think you could still give it to
people.
Oh,
interesting.
Well,
so don't be lying to people and shooting though.
I've only had sex with one chair and he just put his finger up.
I knew it just from the quick,
the quick response.
In most cases,
HPV goes away on its own.
It does not cause any health problems,
but when HPV does not go away,
it causes health problems like genital warts and cancer.
Health care provider can usually diagnose warts by looking at the general area.
What if we can fucking,
oh,
healthcare provider can usually diagnose warts by looking at them.
Yeah.
You
can also do that.
Comedians can also diagnose warts.
You Go,
oh,
that's a Dick Ward.
Interesting.
Yeah,
I had that.
I went to a planned parenthood who do more than abortions.
They'll take your warts right off.
They put a little thing on there and boom.
Here it says there are currently no cure for existing HPV infection,
but for most people would be cleared by their own immune system and there are
treatments available for the symptoms that can cause you can get the HPV vaccine
or they have a vaccine.
That's only for young people though.
We're too old.
Problems apparently causing problems.
What does it do?
I don't know.
He's like,
dude,
you don't lie.
I did not get it.
Oh God.
It just started giving it out recently,
I think in the last like maybe less than 10 years.
But you gotta be,
yeah,
you've got to get it like before you're 18 makes you really horny.
That'd be ideal.
Right?
I don't know if it cures it.
I guess it cures it,
but I had that,
but so it does go away.
Did you ever hear about,
there's a story about a drug called reequip and it was a medication for
Parkinson's disease and Glaxo Smith Kline lost a judgment in court.
I think it was in the tune of $600,000 American because it turned a guy into a
gay sex and gambling addict.
All he wanted to do was hook up with guys online and gamble in.
But listen,
I know it sounds crazy,
but they lost the lawsuit.
Like a pharmaceutical drug company lost a lawsuit and the jury awarded this guy,
well more than a half a million dollars.
How did he prove that all he wants to do is fuck guys.
That's a good question.
But they did.
They proved it to the point where this guy one money,
because he never had any problems like this before,
took this Parkinson's medication and it just was short circuited his brain.
He started sucking Dick and rolling the dice.
I'm going to sue Starbucks.
I've been drinking their tea and now I want to get came on.
Come on.
I can't prove,
I don't want to be come down something about their tea.
It's not organic.
There's a fucking roundup in their teeth or something's up.
But I want some loads while they're starting to pass out lawsuits against
glyphosates speaking to that roundup,
that,
that fucking that,
that shit.
$2 billion and another guy got five,
5 million.
Well,
he needs a better lawyer because he got his lawyer got him 5 million.
The other people's lawyers got them billions.
What?
What is,
what's the drug?
Oh,
it's on a drug.
It's a roundup.
It's a that weed killer.
Shit.
Monsanto weed killer.
Oh,
I see.
Yeah.
It gives people cancer and they're,
they're finally passing down these massive judgements against Monsanto.
Wow.
Yeah.
The weight of it all.
See,
Montana's hold jury hits up,
hits jury with the hits Monsanto with $2 billion judgment.
But there was that one and then there was another one for five plus million.
That guy's gotta be pissed right now.
The fuck did I only get 5 million,
2 billion?
Is that exact or are they rounding up that
count it.
You should open with that tonight at the Improv.
I will on Hollywood.
Hey folks,
you hear about this,
uh,
this,
this thing called roundup.
Most people don't even know what it is.
No,
I just like serious GMO haters.
They're the people that are like super organic,
don't want any pesticides in their foods.
That's one thing that people need to understand.
If you're buying vegetables and you eat a lot of vegetables,
it's very good for you.
But man,
there is a lot of fucking pesticides out there.
This is what's bumming me out.
The more I do cause I didn't always just ate garbage,
whatever without thinking about it.
Now the more I research I do,
the more I'll read about it.
Cause I like to read health benefits of the food I'm eating while I'm eating it
because it makes it feel like,
oh,
all right,
I'm doing something good.
Right?
But then every one,
the bottom of the page,
like if you eat too much broccoli,
you'll shoot your blood or whatever.
There's always something or this pesticides or whatever the fuck.
Yeah.
You the really,
have you heard of a carnivore diet?
You heard of that?
I'm sort,
I,
I assume it's just meat.
It's just me.
Just steak.
Mm.
There's a lot of people that do it and people with autoimmune issues have huge
reactions.
Positive reactions.
Really.
Yeah.
My friend,
he was having receding gum disorder went away and they say that that should
never goes away.
Um,
he lost 50 pounds,
Jordan Peterson.
Oh yeah.
He's on that.
Carnivores dye has been on over a year,
just got his blood work tested.
A lot of people like you shouldn't even recommend that.
It's so irresponsible.
And there's arguments both ways,
man.
His arguments that eating only vegetables as irresponsible because large scale
agriculture is like terrible for the environment.
It displaces all this wildlife and animals and they,
in most cases they're using something to kill the weeds.
And in most cases they're using glyphosate or something like that.
Yeah,
I mean,
I'll,
fruit to me is always like,
that's healthy.
And then people are like,
oh,
it's sugar and you
whatever.
Fiber fruits,
fine.
There's nothing wrong with fruit.
It's like everything else.
If you eat too much fruit,
if you like 10 oranges,
right?
Your body isn't what the fuck bro.
But like if you drink orange juice,
that's not good because your body is like,
where is all the fiber?
Like what is this?
What are you doing to me?
Like,
why are you making me drink this sugar water?
Yeah.
Did he drink like a 12 ounce glass of orange juice?
How,
let's,
let's guess,
how many grams of sugar do you think is in a 12 ounce glass of orange juice?
Uh,
I don't know.
I have not good with this.
I would say,
uh,
can you give me some scale?
Like how much sugar is in a Cocacola I wish I know buck.
I'm going to say 500.
No,
no,
no.
It's okay.
Here's,
here's a good scale.
Like,
like I saw one of those,
um,
Gatorades but not a Gatorade.
Uh,
it was a smart drink that had some fucking flavor to it or something like that.
You know one of them,
but it was 27 grams of sugar that I was like,
Jesus,
that's a lot of fucking sugar.
So I would say orange juice is more than that.
Yeah.
I would say it's got 35 I'd say 30
okay.
I'll say 48 dams going crazy.
What'd he say,
Jamie?
For some reason this thing won't do the math.
Right,
but in one ounce there's 2.6 so time is 12 it's roughly 30 cause it's 24 times
the one plus to six something like that.
Around there.
Yeah.
It's a lot of sugar.
Not 48 though.
No,
fuck me.
You're,
you're only supposed to look for a healthy diet.
I think they split.
You're supposed to be limited to a hundred grams of sugar a day.
And that's for an active person.
Like you really shouldn't fuck around with more than that.
Right?
Yeah.
I feel like I'm finally reaching the age where food becomes a situation.
You've got to start to.
Yeah.
It's part of the problem,
man.
Yeah.
As you get older,
body starts to fucking fall apart on your brow.
Yeah.
My Buddy,
uh,
John Fish I mentioned earlier,
he has a story about,
he went to his doctor and his doctor was like,
in your thirties,
your body starts to break down and in your forties your body starts to die.
And he was waiting for him to like smile or laugh,
but he was like just being serious doctors and asshole.
Yes.
Seems doctor's life right now is fucking a personal trainer.
Like I was super angry about it.
That's probably what's going on there.
Yeah.
I think he's a bad guy.
He's a terrible guy telling you that your body's dying.
Wilson.
I'm alive bitch.
I'll fuck you up right now.
Kill you.
Yeah.
Tell me I'm alive and I'm dying and point.
Fuck.
Shut up.
Shut up doctor.
Doctor Dick Wad.
What kind of doctors that uh,
I don't know,
but some truth to that though specializes in negativity.
Yeah.
No,
you're all alive.
Does it work as good as it does mean you're 20?
No.
Does your fucking car work as good when it has 100,000 miles on it?
But I think what he's saying is that we're on the back,
the back end.
What he should've said is,
Duh,
everybody knows that.
Right?
If you live to be 100 at 40 you're fucking halfway there basically.
Yeah.
Good point.
And living to a hundred is pretty difficult.
Yeah.
If you live to a hundred men,
you get,
you'd really did something.
Yeah.
And most people are not going to make that.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna start trying to make it a hundred.
I wish that there was a thing that showed you when you're dying,
what took it over,
right?
Yeah.
Well they're like,
yeah,
you had one too many cokes in 2007 yeah,
they looked at all the time.
Do you jerked off?
Imagine if like here's an accounting of every time you drove you'd be like,
no,
I think about this all the time.
I wish we could do that.
Cause everything has all these stats now.
You know,
like baseball,
whatever.
I wish you could have all the shifts you've taken,
how many times you've wiped your ass.
How many times do you have jerked off?
How many times you've had sex.
Wouldn't it be fun to have all of those numbers?
It would.
Why can't your phone do that?
It should be how many steps you go.
Yeah.
Use my phone to track how far I run.
Exactly.
So we should start the dude.
I guess we could type it into our phone.
Yeah,
you could.
You could add it up.
You could have like an APP.
Every time you jerk off you have to double tap it.
I feel like that would be a fun thing.
I think we just invented something.
Yeah,
it could be a good app.
Like how many times you jerk off in a year,
Jamie,
how many times you think you drive?
Thousands.
Just say the Apple Watch.
You might know.
Cause one of the last time I got an elliptical it knew I was on the elliptical
within two minutes.
It's like,
oh do you want to track this elliptical workout?
It's like how the fuck do you know that motion of the arm moving?
Is that what it is?
It's gotta be cause there.
There's the,
well that's,
you know,
that's interesting that my zones,
heart rate monitor thing that we were wearing for sober October,
that thing syncs up with my elliptical machine and it shows the heart rate
without even holding onto the heartbreak Bluetooth though.
That's pretty nice.
But it did it without me asking it.
Yeah,
he just did it.
It's close proximity.
I know,
but it's pretty,
pretty crazy that it did that I under what else is interesting to the fucking
government man,
Don,
Don Da.
Um,
are you worried about your phone being tracked?
No.
I have a,
I for some reason I've never cared that much.
I know I should.
And people talk about it like the government watching us and tracking all the
information.
I don't,
uh,
I'm too busy worried about dying and if people like me or not,
I just assume they are.
Yeah,
I don't,
it doesn't,
you know,
I hate to sound like a,
uh,
like some fucking hassle that's like,
oh,
I'm not doing anything wrong.
So spy like,
but I just don't,
it doesn't connect with me to be concerned about that.
Yeah.
I don't think you sound like an asshole.
All right,
good.
Well,
some people were like,
well,
I'm not doing anything wrong.
We want to get the terrorist and blah,
blah,
blah.
Those people are assholes though.
Um,
the people that say that,
what do you care if you're not doing anything wrong?
That's about tyranny starts you weak,
bitch.
Right.
You'd about,
we've been on that guy.
I appreciate this.
Is fake guy talking about
he needs to go get some fucking guns.
Yeah.
Like stand up for America.
Venezuela.
She what's going on first?
Well,
Bro,
they don't have any guns.
It's true actually.
Yeah.
I mean they're running over people in the street because people can't,
it's hard to get guns,
man,
as well.
That's another thing that sometimes things just don't like.
I'll see that story and be like,
oh,
all right,
and then I just can't register everything.
There's no way.
You'll never get any thought done.
Jamie,
what are you going about?
The story of this guy and Holmby hills,
which is like the Beverly Hills area.
Oh yeah,
I heard about that.
He had guns more than a thousand guns.
Yeah.
Making some of them.
He was making them,
not all of them,
but it,
did he do anything?
Did you just like guns?
Uh,
I don't know.
Cause to arrest me tip or something.
If they decided arrest me and they said Joe Rogan has five bows and 150 arrows,
like,
well who the fuck is he planning on killing?
Right.
They could do that.
But those are more firearm sales.
I guess those are less alarming numbers to me though.
Bows 150 arrows.
Thousands seems like a lot.
Yeah,
but I think it's one of those things you just get excited when you keep buying
them.
Acting on a tip regarding illegal firearms hills.
Oh,
okay.
So He's selling guns.
Guns were strewn throughout several of the homes rooms.
Authority said it took about 30 law enforcement personnel more than 12 hours to
remove all the weapons goals,
gun goals,
photos and videos from the scene showed stacks of rifles.
I have a buddy of
mine who has so many guns.
He doesn't know how many guns yeahs.
That's impressive.
That's like us with jerking off.
Yeah,
exactly.
Same thing.
Jerks off too though.
He's a real gun nut,
like a legit gun nut.
Like he,
he does long range shooting.
He goes enters into competitions and stuff where they shoot like,
you know,
they shoot out to like a thousand plus yards.
I tried to understand cause I try to be a good empathetic person.
I'm not a gun guy and it's easy to be like,
what do you need guns?
You fucking maniac.
Right.
But then I'm like,
I understand like I had thousands of baseball cards I guess you get,
they're not killing machines,
but I guess you get into something and then you're like,
I want this gun and then I'm going to try to get another guy.
And then you get addicted to the purchasing of things.
Yeah,
there's that.
But it's also fun to shoot him.
You go to a range.
Like I went to arrange with Duncan Duncan Trussell who's,
well basically a Buddhist and probably one of the most peaceful people I've ever
met in my life and super brilliant guy.
And he's like,
this is so fun.
He fucking loved it.
We loved it.
We just shooting pieces of paper.
You know,
out at distance and clay pigeons and shit.
It's fun.
That seems like fun.
Yeah.
It's also sobering like when you pull the trigger on a rifle and you see that
bullet hit that paper and you're like,
that is car or metal to hear clink.
You know when you're shooting at something it's pretty instant,
right?
Instant.
Yeah.
Mean does when you get to longer distances is kind of interesting cause you pull
the trigger boom and then you hear,
think like there's actually a lag time.
Right.
I think
what kind of distance are we talking?
I've never shot anything further than like 400 yards I think was the longest I
shot anything at the range.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
That's pretty long.
That's what you have taken.
Huge range.
Yeah.
That's four football fields.
You have to,
uh,
set your,
your scope for that.
Or at the very least you have to understand the drop of your bullet.
It's all about how fast your bullet's going.
If you had a pencil and a bullet,
right.
One in each hand and he dropped them both at the same time.
They both fall exactly the same speed because it's a rate of gravity.
So it's all a matter of how fast the bullet gets to the target,
right?
Cause it's going to drop from the moment it comes out of the,
uh,
out of the gun.
It's dropping,
right?
So it's how fast is it going?
There is going to tell you how fast,
how far it's going to drop.
So if you know that you set that use,
you can use ballistics,
um,
uh,
an application,
you take that ballistics information,
you put it into your phone,
like 400 yards,
hundred and 15 grains,
whatever your bullet is at a,
you know,
300 win Mag,
whatever it is,
he enter all that stuff in and then it'll tell you exactly what to do when your
scope,
and then you turn it and then think of,
go right in the center.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's what those a long range dorks.
They love it.
They love shooting things that are really,
really,
really far.
I think they're called snipers.
Well,
it's kind of,
yeah,
but they're not really snipers.
A lot of them are civilians.
Oh,
they're just like,
they just said be long range competitions.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
They have a,
like a guy will be there with a like a super high powered binoculars,
like you know,
fucking big ass scope binoculars and they'll like high left and then calibrate
low.
Right.
And I'll calibrate.
They're just trying to like figure out
like a,
that film jar head.
Did you see that movie?
I did not.
Oh that's good.
Isn't that big?
[inaudible] Hall.
I love Jake Gelatin to,
that's someone I would like to come on my face.
Did you see when he was in that movie when he played a boxer and he got super
ripped?
I did not see that movie,
but someone next to me on the plane was watching it.
So I saw without,
did you get hard hearing it?
I didn't know.
Go look up Jake global and hall.
Um,
it was called a southpaw.
Yes.
Yeah.
You got super shredded.
He's a great look at the actor.
Come on son.
Yeah.
That's something that is fucking jacked.
I mean that is about as shredded as a man gets.
Like,
I worked hard to get that body.
No,
he's amazing.
He's great.
And uh,
that Zodiac is one of my favorite movies.
Broke Back Mountain I love.
And uh,
what's the one with nightcrawler and then prisoners was great too.
I love that movie.
Yeah.
He's been in a bunch of great movies.
He's an interesting cat.
He's good.
Yeah.
There's certain people that like you just want to see them act in that weird.
Yes.
You know,
like they just,
they have a thing.
Yeah.
And then certain people that you like enough of this fucking guy.
There's some people that are famous actors that you're like,
how did this guy get in?
I don't understand what,
drop some names.
Nicholas,
I'm a friend.
This,
this pockets is too big.
These people could be listening.
Could be,
but yeah,
that's why some people got it.
Sacrifice.
There's a couple of guys whose name I don't know,
but I just see him and then like my wife will just,
I'm sorry,
I didn't know he was in this and I'm like,
thank you.
There's a couple of actors that you're like,
this guy sucks.
And he's just a guy.
I don't get it,
you know,
but most of them are occurring.
I feel like most people that are doing well,
a pretty good,
yeah.
Connecting.
Well that's what we would hope.
See this is the thing.
That's
all right.
I hope comes out of this whole me too movement besides these criminals getting
busted is that it changes the whole,
it's like there's a sort of,
uh,
the way thing,
there's an ecosystem out here and I've seen it with women too.
Like there was a woman casting agent that I knew that fucked all these men and
we'd get them parts and she was gross and she was really aggressive to tread.
Fuck my buddy.
She try to fuck two of my buddies.
Yeah.
She sounds nice to me.
I kind of like her foul.
Alright.
My bad breath,
everything's wrong.
Okay.
All right.
I'll take your word for a long time ago.
She's probably dead.
He's probably got HPV and she just died.
It didn't go away.
But,
but I mean,
I've seen it,
I've seen aggressive women.
It's not as many obviously,
but yeah.
But that people would be judged on their merits because it's,
and not just see it's not out here.
Like when you're acting and trying to audition,
it's not just sexual favors.
It's also political leanings.
And like Dale ask you questions about things.
Everyone,
everyone falls in with whatever the ideology that you supposed to adopt in order
to be accepted by this community,
uh,
excel.
They're,
they're really looking for people to say the right things and do the right
things.
They want you to like,
it's not a coincidence that everyone in Hollywood is progressive,
that everyone in Hollywood,
you know,
is super liberal and super left wing.
It's an act for a lot of them,
for good percentage of people out here.
It's a fucking act,
right?
It's a thing that gets you attention and credit,
but couldn't it be part of it?
The,
I mean,
I don't disagree,
but I do think a lot of people that are naturally a artistic,
they become open minded and then they ended up going to the places where they're
very diverse.
And part of becoming progressive I think is meeting a lot of these people that
are,
you know,
gay people and Muslim people and Trans people,
and then you go,
oh,
these people are just like me,
blah,
blah.
From stress of,
yeah,
there's,
that's got to be a part of it.
There's that too,
but
there's such a prevalence of fake humans that you got to realize that like most
of these people have no opinions.
They're not real opinions on what they're doing is they're just sort of spouting
out this predetermined pattern or behavior that they feel like would be
accepted.
Yes.
Oh,
for sure.
And I think,
yeah,
it's set up that way.
Like you said.
I mean,
I'm basically just saying what you just said.
Well,
they just want it so bad.
Right.
You want it so bad.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well that's the danger of,
um,
being motivated by a fame and success.
It's so bad.
That's where I think what helps a lot of comedians is,
it starts off,
the seed is not fame or fortune.
It's like I want to be as funny as,
I want to bring as much joy to the audience as I can.
So as long as you can keep that,
you end up being a a pretty decent person and a good artist.
Yeah.
You just want to kill.
The thing about,
there's some traps in that too,
right?
And this is one of the traps that leads to people stealing material is that you
just want to kill,
you want to kill you.
Wanna you want to feel that feeling,
right?
So you want it.
It's not that you want the audience to have it,
so you want to kill in the way you kills.
They have a great time,
but you will do that at any cost.
So you'd take other people's work and try to pawn it off at your own as your
own.
You pretend to be someone you're not,
so they'll like you more so they will,
you'll kill louder.
I'm afraid someone's going to take this clip where you keep saying you and it
just showing maybe like,
I'm sorry,
someone's definitely gonna be,
this is like a Colin.
Colin Quinn used to have that old joke.
He's like,
don't tell you the story.
And they use you as,
he's like,
you're telling me you sleep with kids and you think that's okay.
And he's like,
not me,
I'm not the guy.
But,
but yeah,
that,
that is a weird thing that people do.
The design,
you're telling me you think it's okay to rob Old Lady?
Yeah.
And just people walking by.
I didn't say that.
No,
I know you didn't say that,
but they don't hear that part.
These fucking guys who rob old ladies.
MMM.
But yeah,
that,
that definitely is a bit,
but I try to be,
uh,
in tune with that too,
like in a meditative way of that.
Like,
cause you get so as a community gets so obsessed with just like the sound of
killing,
wanting to kill it,
you forget that they're actually a group of human beings.
Right.
And then you're like,
you are,
the goal is to bring joy to the people that you're actually trying to get laughs
and trying to,
um,
feel the joy of providing joy as opposed to just like,
if I kill,
I'll get on TV and if I get on TV I can pitch my show.
I try to kind of organically walk it back to the room in the moment of making
these people here at labs.
That's a great attitude,
but I think New York is better in that regard in that there's not really a lot
of industry.
Right.
It's really just about killing since about being funny.
Yeah.
Doing well.
It feels like a lot of the motivation in New York is to kill,
so you'll get more seller spots the next week.
Yes.
As opposed to I'll kill so I can get in the room with
true TV or whatever.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
You don't want,
that's a,
I'm hoping that goes away and I think it is,
that's one thing that's kind of reinvigorated the Los Angeles scene is actually
the death of jobs,
believe it or not.
Like there's no jobs for comedians anymore other than being a comedian.
Right.
So because,
and also because of podcasts and the Internet,
because people can put their clips up on youtube and because people can do
things on the Internet,
there is no longer like the really important stuff for your career is no longer
held by these gatekeepers.
Like the network executives that are constantly there.
They're never there anyway.
Like if you haven't,
if you get a show approved by a network executive,
there's a real good shot that in six months that person won't be there anymore.
Right,
right.
Real good shot.
Yeah,
that's like that.
It feels like in the hole industry,
somebody bookers you in comedy starting out,
you try to impress this booker or get in with them where were like kind of
hanging out and like having a beer and the next thing you know they're like
in accounting,
they're not even in the business anymore.
The good thing about today though is there's more comradery amongst comedians
than ever than ever before.
And there's more support amongst communities cause comedians do each other's
podcasts.
And on the podcast you'll talk about each other and sometimes it's bad.
Like how we're shitting on art should fear cause I'm fucking really tired.
Ari,
aren't you?
Uh,
I'm,
I'm not.
You have known him a lot longer.
You know I love him.
I'm just kidding.
But I mean sometimes it is bad though.
If someone gets exposed,
if someone,
you know,
like someone does piss you off or someone is doing something unethical and you
find out about it through a podcast.
But for the most part,
most comedians,
these podcasts are being like super supportive.
Yeah.
No,
it's the best.
I mean I think most things I've gotten in my career from other Comedians,
yeah.
At this point.
Yeah.
I think that's real normal.
And it's normal east coast and west coast and it didn't use to be like that.
There wasn't this like really super supportive community out there anymore,
but there wasn't always,
I think it's the podcast thing I really do because so many people have podcasts.
Yeah.
Well.
It's
also contagious when someone does so much for you and brings you on the road and
buys you lunch and tweets your shit,
you're like,
I want to do that for somebody.
And so then it keeps calling for it.
It's a good feeling.
It's a nice to be nice to the nice,
yeah,
it's a great feeling.
And you really get to know,
like
Ari's podcasts,
one of my favorite podcasts because he,
you get to know him in his podcast,
like he does these,
he'll do an intro that's 40 minutes long for a conversation and it's him stoned,
wandering around his apartment,
cooking salmon and talking about it and like,
and talking about this and that and something that sucks.
And this is stupid and that's great.
And you know,
it's like you get to hear him.
Yeah,
no,
ours is a,
a,
a special,
not to sound like a fucking fruitcake,
but he's a special human being.
I love that guy.
Yeah.
He's
about him more than anything is,
well,
I love a lot of things about him,
but he figured out who he was and got successful and when he got successful he
gave zero fucks.
Once he got successful,
it's like,
okay,
I've got a couple of hundred thousand dollars in the bank,
you can all suck my ass.
And he doesn't,
he doesn't compromise anything.
Yeah.
And he takes care of people in a way that I'm like,
I'm concerned about your fine.
It like he'll do a show and split the door evenly with everybody.
And uh,
I'm like,
you should take the money.
You sold it out.
You hosted the show,
you produce the show.
Like I've done his storytelling show and he's like,
here's $860.
And I told like an eight minute story and didn't even do great.
I'm like,
ah,
I'm sorry.
That sucked.
He's like,
whatever,
here's $900.
And you're like,
okay,
like you could have paid me 100 bucks.
It's like a Tuesday and I would have blown you.
Um,
but that's the way he is.
He come in my face,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm not going to swallow that you load.
Um,
but then I've produced a show with him.
We did a show together and then sweat.
It fucks you.
The splitting the money where I'm like,
I don't want to fucking split the money.
Yeah,
that's true.
that does.
Fuck you.
Especially if it's your show.
But no,
he's a,
he's a great guy.
We just went out and hiked in,
uh,
Mount Zion and um,
does that Utah,
Zion national,
maybe I might've made the mountain part up Zion national forest.
Yeah.
I don't know if there's a mountain vault at Utah in Utah.
But he liked paid for the airbnbs where all the fucking has the wild rock
formations and shit.
Yeah.
It's pretty,
it's pretty amazing.
Yeah.
But um,
he got this like airbnb that was like seven bedrooms in a hot tub and he paid
for the whole thing to him.
And then I got this reflux thing,
so we made all this special food for me and to you guys.
That's us right there.
I'll look at that.
That's Mike Vecchio and,
and my wife Sarah,
Tele Mush and myself.
Did you see any mountain lions or any crazy shit when you're out there?
We saw nothing crazy.
I mean it was,
it was beautiful and amazing,
but nothing insane is beautiful.
That was the house he got.
It was like their BNB.
It's like a retreat for like,
did all these crazy drums in there and a big fireplace,
indoor,
outdoor.
It was pretty unbelievable.
Oh,
you know the weird thing about airbnb's as you find like little fucking webcams
where people are watching you.
24,
seven.
Wow.
That's the backyard.
And that's the back porch.
Yeah.
Fuck.
That view is amazing.
And then the next day my wife and I drove to Sunnyvale,
California.
We all said goodbye.
I was going to do rooster teeth.
Feathers.
Oh.
And we went to the mall to eat and uh,
all of our shit got robbed.
Everything I'm wearing,
everything she's wearing is uh,
stolen.
We had this big,
like meditative xy on hiking three days together and you just feel like,
man,
fucking life,
Bro.
And then we went to the cheesecake factory.
I was starving.
I'm like,
I gotta eat something.
And we came out and 100% of our luggage and computers were stolen out of your
car.
Yeah.
Which I guess is an epidemic in the,
uh,
what's that called?
Silicone Valley.
Really huge San Jose San Francisco to the point where the cops were like,
oh yeah,
all right,
take care.
Did they break into your car?
I guess they went into the trunk,
but I thought maybe I didn't lock the door.
But a bunch of people have tweeted that may saying they have like fucking
decoder things.
They can just get into cars now.
Jesus,
they pray on rental cars cause they know you have suitcases and shit.
They see that little no smoking thing.
Oh,
and that's the thing.
It's silicone valley.
Yeah.
So that after that happened,
we noticed every restaurant would go to,
would see at least like one business guy with eating with a suitcase next to
them were like,
you gotta bring your shit inside.
Oh it was brutal.
Silicone Valley's a weird spot because you have all these really rich people and
then you have all fucking army of homeless folks.
Yeah.
I mean that feels like America.
And getting more and more that somebody was telling me this,
Jamie,
find out if this is true because someone was telling me that there's a woman
that I know that lives out here and she was saying that they bust people bust
them in from other cities.
They take their homeless people and give them one way tickets to Los Angeles.
I heard that with Hawaii.
Is that what you said?
No.
Oh,
I heard that it happens in Hawaii.
They fly him to Los Lunas.
That's a good move.
If you're in Hawaii,
good luck getting a ticket back.
Fuck yeah.
But it's,
but if your boss them they could always get back.
Yeah.
They're on the same piece of ground.
Right.
It's not as effective.
That's a good point.
Patient flying to Hawaii.
That's what La should send them back.
Yeah.
Save a lot of money.
I think there's a few jumbo jets.
Get one of them.
Eight 37 tens of crash and make it a,
I think you should make it a night like I'll fucking private like a air force
one with is like food and uh,
you know,
focus the sizer and then they're like,
oh wow,
this is going to be great.
And then you're like,
no,
it ain't.
Yeah,
you fly him in the Molokai.
That's that,
that island that they used to send the lepers.
So there's an article,
I just found that that was done by the Guardian and 2017 seems like a pretty
long in depth article.
It doesn't say they're being busted specifically to Los Angeles,
but this one,
the example they're giving is a purchase,
a ticket purchase to this guy by the city of San Francisco.
And I think this was sending him to Indianapolis.
So he went,
wow,
2100 miles the other way.
How weird is that?
That should be so illegal to not take care of your homeless problem,
but rather to send them,
he traveled 2,275 miles over three days to reach his destination in Indianapolis
and then freeze to death.
You don't magically go from San Francisco to Indianapolis.
You don't have the proper footwear at fuck.
Cities have been offering homeless people free bus tickets to relocate elsewhere
for at least three decades.
What that is gross.
Well,
if you're just offering them a ticket,
yeah,
but it's not so bad until now.
There's never been a systematic nationwide assessment of the consequences.
Where are these people being moved to?
What is the impact those programs are having on the cities that send and the
cities that received them and what happens to these homeless people after they
reached their destination?
Well,
the best example of that was a,
that wild wild country documentary.
Yeah,
I did.
I mean they've took over fucking talent with homeless folks.
Yeah.
That was one of those ones.
Every cult thing I watched the first half hour I'm like,
this seems pretty nice.
I'm kind of,
yeah,
like this sounds kind of awesome.
And then slowly are like,
aw,
maybe it's poisoning people.
Fuck.
It was a science geology.
It was like that.
Yeah.
I was watching like a half hour and I was like,
I kind of am into this religion.
Which one going clear the HBO deliverance,
right?
One.
Alex?
Yeah.
Alex,
give me,
I think maybe,
yeah,
it's Lawrence Wright's book.
Go and clear.
The book is even more bizarre because it gets obviously like way more into depth
about how crazy l Ron Hubbard was and what he essentially did and how he started
this whole thing.
And he's,
he was self analyzing.
It was trying to heal himself because he was fucking crazy.
And along the way he got really into psychology and self help books and then was
quoted saying if you want to make real money you start a religion and then
started a religion.
Well he's not wrong.
He was right.
I did all right.
This is right.
Watch this graphic that they used on here.
I'll have to scroll down and make it activate.
But it's,
it shows their data showing all these homeless people get sent around the
country.
Whoa.
Just like those little dots.
So there's sending them from Los Angeles in New York primarily look at the loads
those berms by a year.
I can't show the whole graphics cause we can't see.
It was crazy.
Like,
what is that burst?
Is that burst from,
was that southern California or that looks like San Francisco,
San Francisco to be up here.
This would be la,
like San Diego,
but Florida seems to have the most started in Florida.
This graphic starts out in Florida.
Wow.
Would that make sense?
It's when the hurricanes,
I think two is around that time period when they got smashed and I liked the
idea of,
I like one's passing each other though.
Like there's two homeless guys passing each other like ships in the night cares
where you don't see him.
Lynn,
Texas,
Texas doesn't give a fuck.
Those are shoot you,
they'll shoot you.
They have a whole for homeless people like that they have out in the desert.
Why not like Wyoming?
They don't have enough people up there.
Bears.
It's fucking hard to live up there.
They're just not interested in taking it in.
You're homeless.
Yeah.
That's uh,
you know,
when you wait by the time you get to be a certain age and you're homeless,
I guess you just have to accept the fact
that this is just life.
This is the life you've,
no.
Yeah,
it seems unpleasant.
I enjoy having a home personally.
Me Too.
I like it.
Yeah.
I like going in there.
I read recommend and one with a lock.
Yeah,
that's the best.
So you could sleep.
Yeah.
Do you like living in New York?
I love it.
Yeah.
But I'm on the road so much that it's idea where I'm like,
I'm never home for really more than like 10 days.
Which would,
New York is ideal.
You ever think about moving down here?
Not really.
I mean,
yeah,
the answer is yes,
but I don't think I will because I'm like a road dog.
So La is tough because you're behind the eight ball with the Thai,
like most,
you're three hours behind most of the markets.
Oh,
for flights.
Yeah.
So you've got to get up at like 6:00 AM or leave the day before.
And I liked the comedy cellar.
I like being there.
I like doing those like quality spots and you can kind of do multiple.
I,
my family's in New England.
I like going home to see them.
Do you work when you're in a new England as well?
Yeah,
I do like laugh.
You laugh Moscow.
Yeah.
It's cool.
I'm there some point in November,
like Thanksgiving or something to be a hundred fucking comedy clubs in Boston.
There used to be so many and now there's just slap Austin and like what else?
There's the Wilbur.
Yeah.
The Wilbur and comedy stop still around.
Nix is still around.
Yeah.
That's crazy that that place is still around.
That's been there forever.
But,
uh,
worked there 30 years ago.
That's amazing.
I worked there 18 years ago.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
the comedy connection was like my home.
You did that when Faneuil Hall,
right?
Yeah.
That was amazing.
Is that where you started?
Yeah,
I didn't start.
I started a place called chops lounge,
which was like a true open mic where it was like street people and fucking main
people that had been bused in from San Francisco.
It was like a sign up and go on and uh,
they'd be like a mixture of comics and then just Weirdos.
And so I started there and then I went,
uh,
eventually the comedy connection,
I started working there,
but that's where I first started opening for people and doing like real comedy
work and it kind of spawned from there.
I mean it's weird for us,
but you know where who it's really weird for.
It's really weird if you try to like do open mics and you're like a singer.
Yeah.
I don't know how that works.
It doesn't work well,
it works terrible.
Yeah.
It was comics that would go to like music,
open mikes.
I mean there are music open mics,
right.
I guess I went to a poetry slam open Mike once I've been to comedy shows that
feel like poetry slams all in New York.
You get a lot of that.
Yeah.
Right.
Where you're just like,
what I heard there's a lot of like really re re ridiculous sort of like woke
comedy being performed.
Yeah,
definitely.
There's a thing where it's now become oddly hacky.
They don't realize that.
You're like,
well this is now hack right.
Where you're like,
ah,
Trump or a white male privilege.
Which I'm like,
yeah,
I understand it's an issue.
Whenever you're like seven other comics started their sentence with that same
thing,
but to be able to say that about me saying sex jokes,
whatever white male privilege is
only a problem because of racism and because of sexism.
If racism and sexism are out of the picture,
it's not your fault,
your fault.
You're a white male.
The problem is that some people are not white males.
If you're a black woman and you encounter prejudice everywhere you go and
discrimination everywhere you go,
the problem is the discrimination.
It's not Joe lists being a white male,
they've fucked the whole thing up,
right?
Because they've really created resistance where there should be none because
you've made people perpetrators when they've done nothing wrong,
like you just were born a white male.
You got unlucky the same way or you got lucky,
I should say,
depending on your perspective.
I mean,
they didn't ask to be born a black woman.
Someone didn't ask to be born a Polynesian man.
You are who you are.
You just,
you are.
The real problem is people that care.
The people that look at you and go,
oh,
it's a fucking white man.
Great.
That's what I want the opinion of another white man like that is the real
problem.
The real problem is that sexism.
That is what racism and I don't even think it is because they think you're white
and you have white privilege,
but you're discriminating based on something that someone has zero control over.
Yeah,
I agree.
It's fucking horse shit.
Yeah,
it's a fun.
I feel bad.
I was like,
I'm just trying to tell my Dick and shit jokes and get my 25 bucks and get Outta
here.
Yeah.
But that,
that's like,
like I said,
people can look at my act and be like,
he's talking about dicks and shit.
I talk about all kinds of things sometimes Dixon shit too though.
Yeah.
Well those are funny.
Things can be discussed.
Well Dixon Shits are funny often.
Yeah,
I have to like,
yeah.
Okay.
Curb myself from having,
I'm like,
I got too many shit jokes now.
This is like 12 minutes.
I've got a few,
I've got a chunk.
But it's funny.
Shit.
It's shit.
It's funny.
You know,
sometimes you just get on a run where that's what you're interested in.
Yeah.
Well also once you have a bit that's working,
you want to extend it and write other things about it.
So then that's the way it goes.
I had a time period where I had like four bits about aliens.
Yeah.
And I was like,
God damn,
this is too much.
You almost,
once you get to a certain point,
you start going,
what?
Can I just go all the way and just do a one man show about aliens?
Go to the Edinburgh fringe festival.
I'll just be the alien guy.
Yeah,
I bet you could.
It could be like,
uh,
have a slideshow behind you.
Yeah.
Seti research.
Oh,
fucking the big dish that you see in the movie contact Jodie foster.
Yeah.
I'm not familiar with that movie.
Well,
I mean,
I'm familiar with,
I never,
I wasn't into it.
He didn't see that.
Never been a big Italian guy.
No,
you're not a believer.
MMM.
I feel like this is the kind of place where you could produce an alien.
I'm like,
no,
not really.
I'm not a fucking thing comes and raped me.
Why?
We'll show you the aliens,
but you're going to have to not be sober.
Oh.
Oh,
you,
you're fully sober guy.
Yeah.
Did you,
you said that was not sober guy.
Yeah,
I was,
uh,
yeah,
we'll you a mess.
Yeah.
Mentally I felt like a mess.
I mean,
I wasn't,
I never killed anybody or anything,
but I was at,
I mean,
I'm an alcoholic.
Yeah.
I shit in the girl's shoe and yeah.
I had some fun.
Oh yeah.
Girl Shoe.
Why,
what did she do to you?
Uh,
nothing just invited me to stay at her house.
I don't remember doing it.
I was in a blackout or whatever,
but um,
yeah,
I was all fucked up and then I woke up and uh,
I had to Piss so bad.
Like I just woke up in a bed and I was like,
I got a pen and I was like,
let me,
I don't know where I am.
I actually had a flight.
I had a cross.
I was going to the Seattle comedy competition.
Do you ever do that?
No.
It was like,
it's like a month long competition and uh,
yeah.
And it's not,
they call it Seattle,
but it's like actually all over Washington state.
It's like a,
you drive like three hours a night.
It's pretty crazy.
Yeah.
But,
um,
I had to like be there the next day for a month.
I had like a 10:00 AM flight and I woke up at like nine 20 in the morning and
this girl's bed and I was like,
I gotta get the hell out of here.
But first I gotta Piss.
If I piss in this woman's bed,
it's going to be,
it's going to be horrible.
So I ran to the bathroom,
found the bathroom,
pissed for like a half hour,
you know,
those and I've tried to like put my shit to get my,
I'm all fucked up.
And then I came out into her living room and uh,
her table had been like smashed like a Chris Farley fucking table mother.
And you're that feeling when you're fucked up,
we are looking at something and you're like,
that was definitely me.
I can just feel like,
ah,
I'm pretty sure I'm responsible for that.
And then I was like,
I've got to go find my clothes.
So I went back into her room and uh,
on the way there I saw like kind of like footprints of poop.
And then I came in and she had a high top Nike sneaker that just had like a big
[inaudible] out there.
Yeah.
And there was some little pieces around.
And then there was like a big puddle of urine too.
Like I didn't just,
cause you never just shit.
So I like pissed and shit,
but I got it in her sneaker.
Like I fucking nailed it.
Purpose.
Well,
I think,
I mean,
I was in a blackout so by,
but I think what happened was I thought it was a toilet because that's not like
my sense of humor.
I'm not like a,
I've never been like a take a shit places.
So I think I just saw a cylinder twin.
Well,
if it's dark,
it looks it's black and it's a whole,
how big is her fucking choose real big feat.
It was um,
it was a big woman.
No.
So I shit in there.
And then what did what,
did you lose contact with her after this?
No.
So I was like,
I gotta get Outta here cause I gotta go catch this flight.
So I took my sock and put it on like a,
like a puppet,
like a hand puppet,
a sock puppet and just kind of picked it up that way and then turn the sock
inside out.
Right.
Which like,
like almost like a shit in a sock and threw that away.
And I tried to wipe up as much of the,
she asleep?
No,
no,
they're gone.
Oh my God.
So I thought it's like nine 30 in the morning.
I thought I just went so crazy.
They all fled their own home.
So then I get in the cab to go to the airport.
I'm missing my flight and I texted the girl and I was like,
I am so I want to kill myself.
Like I can never,
I show sorry.
Did you tell her that I should know?
Well,
I figured she knew.
So wrote back.
It's okay.
Uh,
it was,
it was crazy,
crazy night.
It was fun or whatever and I was like,
man,
this girl must fucking party.
Like she's just like okay with the shitting I'll say this woman's wild.
So then I got to the airport,
flew across the country,
miss my flight flood,
got the next flight out on the plane.
I like crossed my leg at one point and realized I had shit like up my pant leg.
It's like subtly put it down.
I was at a middle seat for a full cause I missed my phone side of your pond.
The panel outside of my pay.
How much?
Shit.
Just like a good streak.
Like I would say ankle to knee.
He didn't go to the bathroom and tried to clean it up?
No,
cause I was already on the plane.
I was in the middle seat and I was like caked on there.
It was like hours later.
Oh my God.
So then I landed,
took the plane and I phone off of airplane mode and had a text that was like,
Holy Shit.
We had no idea how bad it was.
And I was like,
that makes more sense.
That is a better reaction cause I thought they must.
So the crazy part is I shit it was like nine in the morning they had left for it
was your shit.
Yeah.
They didn't have a dog and I sued,
they don't just shit in their own shoes.
So,
um,
I was,
I wanted to post it but then I was late so I had to go straight to the show and
I ended up with shit on your pants?
Yeah,
with shit in my pants and my leg.
It was like cake to my leg hair.
And it was the first time they come the fishing?
No,
I don't think anybody smelled it.
I don't think they noticed cause I think it would have been,
I don't know.
No one said anything.
So this is funny because shit,
so then I finished,
I took a shower finally,
like 12 hours later I was actually,
I remember pulling little pieces of shit out of my leg hair.
It was the best shower in my life.
It felt,
oh,
how was your set?
Good.
I killed.
And I ended up winning that night cause they each night you judged.
I came in like first place.
It was like one of the best sets I've ever had.
That sounds like a real comedian show,
but shit on your legs and you win a competition but fucking kill.
I love it.
It was pretty short.
It was pretty fun.
And then I ended up sending this message to these women.
I have the messages on Facebook so it lives forever,
but it's about like this law,
it's like a 12 inch.
It just keeps going.
And I'm like,
I want to kill myself.
I don't know how this happened.
I really wanted to die.
And they were,
luckily they were like 22 they were like fresh out of college.
So they were like pretty lol forgiving.
Yeah.
But they're in their thirties I would have sent you a bunch of crying emojis.
No,
they were just like laughing,
crying one with the tears.
Yeah.
That's my favorite one.
So I sent 'em 300 bucks in a car.
I called my friend Nate Barr Gatsy and uh,
I was like,
how much is 300 bucks?
Like a good amount and he's like,
he's from Tennessee.
He's like,
I don't think there's an amount you can see the stupid.
So I sent him a card with 300 bucks and um,
I didn't really keep in touch with them,
but they were,
they were nice.
They were like,
hopefully you don't get that fucked up again.
And then by the way,
I drank that and I kept drinking for two more years.
You think that'd be like a bottom?
And then I remember that night being like,
well,
I'm going to drink again at some point.
I might as well.
So I drank for like two more years.
Then I got herpes and I tried to stop then to,
and then I just kept going,
fuck it.
Yeah.
And what made you hit bottom?
I finally just a live fucking hated myself.
I still do a little bit,
but not as much.
And uh,
I just,
it wasn't fun.
I knew I had to quit.
It's like same as food at sounds like at some point I've got to stop doing this
isn't a normal amount of drinking.
And then,
um,
it just fucking,
it kind of happy.
I tried to stop a couple times and,
uh,
I'd go like a few days and then one day it was just like a thing of like,
let me,
I'm going to,
this is it.
I'm stopping now.
I remember my brother in law,
his father had just died.
It was Christmas is,
and I was like,
making a joke,
you know,
when you're drunk,
trying to be funny.
And I was like busting his balls about his dad and he was like,
yeah,
I'm upset.
I remember just feeling like such a fucking piece of shit.
And then,
uh,
I remember like kind of the day after Christmas,
I was like,
I kinda just blacked out Chris.
Like I came home and I was like,
I don't even remember what the fuck.
And I was like,
I gotta stop.
And then I was at field,
uh,
helium in Philadelphia and I stocked up.
Yeah.
And I was with Gary Gulman is opening for Gary Gulman also.
My career was like kind of shit.
I was like 16 years at 15 years in whatever.
Oh actually less than that.
12 years.
And I guess,
um,
and I was like,
I gotta do something.
I'm going to turn this around.
And I just stopped and I got fucking really into it,
into sobriety.
And it's like a new a life.
You're like,
oh,
everything feels new again and fresh again.
I'm like,
I'll go back to this,
I'll get into sports again,
I'll go to museums.
You're not tired all the time.
Yeah.
And then you just feel better.
You have the feel better things.
Huge.
That's,
that's the problem is you're tired all the time.
Like when you,
if you drink a lot,
you're always like a little bit behind the eight ball.
Well,
I would lose days of my life because I was just hung over.
I felt like shit.
And then I realized for basically a decade I was drunk or hungover or just
foggy,
like where you turn your head and it takes a moment for everything to kind of
like catch up this fucking foggy.
And um,
and just like that deep hatred.
And I knew I had to go all in and like I gotta I can't,
I'm not a guy that's like,
I'll have a beer.
And I never had that.
Even now when I think about,
I've sober almost seven years,
six and a half years,
even now when I think about a drink,
I'm not like,
that'd be fun to have a beer.
I'm like,
ah,
I'd be fun to have fucking 500 beers right now.
You know what I mean?
Just to go whole hog and yeah,
it again.
Yeah.
So I did,
the problem was,
you know,
when you quit [inaudible] gets still be like the first 90 days.
They're like,
just don't worry about anything except for not drinking,
just eat whatever,
do whatever.
And so I started doing that with food.
I was like,
I'm eating cookies.
And then I just never started.
So then I just did that for years with food and now that's kind of caught up to
me.
What do you do you think now and how many years you've been sober now?
About six and a half.
So you're just sober now.
You're cool with it as who you are.
Yeah.
Imagine if he did a show called Joe list gets fucked up where it's like you,
you have handlers to make sure you don't Shit on anybody shoe if everything
taken care of
and you go,
look,
I haven't had a drink in six years,
but I'm sober now.
I'm content being sober.
But for tonight and tonight only we're having a one night Joe list gets fucked
up special and you just started a bar and start getting hammered.
I think I would have to perform early and then I'm doing a show.
Uh,
no,
no.
The show would be just following you around with cameras while you get blasted.
Okay.
Cause I was gonna say if it's a show,
I'd have to do it earlier.
I'd have to have like two beers because then I'd be sobbing and be like,
ah,
my fucking,
I've found,
uh,
yeah.
So see she has now been so bad,
no time zero.
That's the motivated one of the motivating,
I mean there's a lot,
but like the idea of going back to like,
um,
day one,
it's like such a,
um,
which happens and it's part of getting sober.
Then people go,
I don't want to disparage people that are having that happen,
but like,
it's such a bummer to fucking walk back in there and be like,
oh one day.
And you know,
it happens.
Of course.
I knew a lot of guys who had that dude get sober fuck year dive back in and
yeah,
I went,
well I tried early on I tried to quit drinking and then I was like,
oh,
I'll smoke pot though cause I don't have,
and then you realize with wheat,
like I'm like,
oh,
I'm outside of my mind.
This is the same as I'm fucked up.
Like where you get high enough,
you're like,
well this is not sobriety.
I'm fucking retarded right now.
Right,
right.
Was,
was your thing just not being in your mind getting outside of your mind or was
your thing blacking out and ruining your life?
Cause the thing,
the only thing that's good about pot is you don't feel terrible.
Yeah.
Well I think I have like that addictive personality.
So then that'd be high.
But now it does seem like more,
uh,
appealing.
Cause nowadays,
first of all,
it's like you can go to store and the guy that's like this weed makes you feel
happy.
This one chills you out.
This one makes you gay.
This one's great.
Yeah.
Like before when I was,
I just never a big weed guy,
but I'd get drunk and smoke and sometimes you're just smoke some fucking crazy
demon weed and be out of your mind.
It was just whatever.
We'd was just weed.
Now it feels like there's categories and shit.
Dude,
I did a be real smoke box,
you know,
be real from Cypress Hill.
I had,
I do now.
I know Cypress Hill be real is uh,
you know,
the guy who would talk wraps in the crazy high pitch voice doctor fee.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Um,
I did his smoke box and you get in this Cadillac and you smoke weed until you
are no longer even a person.
You are just,
uh,
you are a thought that is like a cork that's flowing down a raging river,
headed to a waterfall.
Like you are so fucked up and you're trying to have a conversation and you're
being filmed.
And these guys do that every day.
They just,
there's people that just get up biliterate it every day.
Yeah.
I think that sometimes we'd,
people don't take it sit cause it's like
it's just weed and it's uh,
it's natural,
whatever.
But sometimes there's people that I'm like,
yeah,
but you're fucked up all day every day.
Yeah.
If you have an addictive personality and you have a problem with anything,
there's a lot of people that get into that Kratom stuff.
Do you know what that stuff is?
[inaudible] Kratom as um,
it's like a plant based.
I think people are trying to call it an opiate.
I don't know if it's technically an opiate,
but it's legal.
You can buy it and it helps people and it actually alleviates a lot of the
symptoms of opiates and it acts as a mild stimulant.
When you take a little bit of it,
like if you take two pills,
it's like a cup of coffee and it's like,
oh,
I like,
this is nice.
But then I said,
I wonder what it's like.
And I was asking a friend of mine who takes it all the time,
I go,
how much do you take?
And he's like,
I take 10 pills,
I got 10 you take 10.
I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
Like?
So I did it.
I tried it.
I think I took eight,
I don't even think I took 10 and I was fucked up.
I was like,
oh you guys are getting high.
Like this is your high.
I'm high right now.
Like this is not like you're not sober.
Don't tell me you're sober.
And you take an eight pills.
A cranium like that stuff gets you high and you can,
you can buy it legally,
but it's weird high.
It's like,
um,
everything functions like your,
your muscles and your arms.
And everything moves the way it's supposed to.
It doesn't feel like you're on coordinated or,
or you're tripping and stumbling or anything like that.
But your brain is like,
this is not sober.
It's just like screaming.
This is not sober,
but it's a different kind of,
this is not sober.
Interesting.
Yeah,
you're not,
you're like I could have a conversation with you and you might not even know
that it was fucked up on this stuff.
Right.
And I could go lift weights are going to go do something or you wouldn't,
it wouldn't impair like you'd go running on that stuff.
So is it like a heady buzzer?
Like a body to anything?
It's a head.
It's a weird one.
Like I was really shocked at how high God.
Hmm.
Cause I felt like,
cause that's what someone said,
they said if you take two pills,
it has a mild stimulant effects and we're in a cup of coffee.
But if you take multiple pills then it becomes more of like a like a,
like a Downer or not.
Not a downer.
More relaxing,
more like an opiate.
But I didn't realize how fucked up you actually get.
Like you get pretty fucked up and then you get a tolerance for it.
So a lot of these guys are taking like 10 pills,
then going to the gym and they're like,
oh,
I need it for my back.
I'm like,
you can't even blasted.
Yeah,
that's like that with booze and all drugs.
It feels like you kind of chase that yeah.
Thing.
I mean that's,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing,
right?
It's like we were talking about with smart phones or like we were talking about
video games,
like things get get away from you.
Yeah.
That's part of the problem with being a comic.
Right?
Like all of us,
if there's something wrong with your brain,
want to do this,
right?
Yeah.
I think there's definitely some sort of design this,
some attention.
You didn't get somewhere something went wrong.
You're upset about it.
And so,
uh,
when you're not on stage or when you're honest,
you're trying to do something else to make you forget about that attention or
affection.
You didn't get somewhere along the line.
Yeah.
It's a fucking,
if you can harness it though,
like that I didn't get enough attention
can be super beneficial and gives you insight.
Yeah.
It'll give you motivation if you can harness it.
It's interesting to go,
um,
that sort of self reflecting and therapy or whatever that,
whatever your method is,
or people do it with mushrooms or whatever,
but that introspective of like,
oh,
those moments where you're like,
I'm doing that because of that.
That's neat.
Yeah.
Then there's the next step of no longer doing the things you don't want to do
because of that or the habits that you have and the next step,
you go to the rom.center and Malibu start doing acid.
Oh,
I don't think a malleable they have it.
Where's,
where's the dot?
Oh,
Maui dunking.
Dunking goes to Maui every year.
Hangs out when Rahm Dawson.
Wow.
They meditate.
Yeah.
People come from all over the world to meet this guy and meditate with them.
That's pretty amazing.
I listened to a,
I love a tech,
not Han.
You know that guy?
No.
Oh,
he's a,
he's a Buddhist monk.
I think he's about to die.
I think he's like in his nineties,
he hung out with like MLK back in the day.
They'll,
okay.
Nominated for the Nobel peace prize.
He's written like 70 books.
He's a pretty amazing tick.
Not Hot.
It's t,
H I c h space and h a.
T.
Where's he from?
He's from Vietnam,
but now he's been in,
he's been living in France for like,
I don't know,
30 years.
He's got his own meditation center,
but he writes all these books and there's videos you can find.
Do you meditate?
I do.
I tried.
Sometimes I just,
I'm such a fucking anxious guy that it's sometimes hard,
but I'd read him a lot.
And Jack Kornfield Buddhists that's tech not,
Huh?
Yeah,
that 90 years old.
He's close.
He's in is an old picture problem.
Great.
But I also,
yeah,
I mean he's a,
he's a real zen master,
so yeah.
So maybe he's going to live forever or some shit.
Um,
and then Tara Brock,
I listened to her pose.
He's old as fuck now.
Her Dad,
that makes more sense.
Um,
I'll listen to her like guided meditation.
I'll do that,
but I use an APP.
I just heard her podcast has like a,
she does these guided ones,
so not an app but a podcast and then sometimes I'll just sit.
Have you ever done a float tank yet?
No.
Your guy,
I don't know what the producer I guess was showing it to me,
but I feel like I'd have a fucking panic attack in there.
He just opened the door anytime you want.
Oh,
okay.
It's not like it closes you in.
Yeah,
it seems terrifying.
The door to school,
like just like that.
Just touch it gently.
It'll open nothing.
That's good to know.
But no,
I've never,
I've never done it.
I should,
but yeah,
I've had panic disorder throughout my life and I just for the first time and
like a long time,
had a couple of panic attacks last week for the first time in two years.
Yeah.
What was fucking with you?
I think a lot.
There's like,
uh,
well first of all doing this show is anxiety and of now I feel like we're just
bullshitting.
I'm just trying to pretend there's not.
That's how it always is.
Lesser of people listening.
I'm glad that you got there because when we said in the beginning like we almost
start,
do you want to tell people,
you were telling me that you were kind of anxious,
like,
well let's,
let's just talk.
Let's just,
I worked at disarming but,
oh well I'm not trying to be,
I appreciate it.
I appreciate it that you are,
but I think a lot of it is like,
yeah,
this is a huge show.
And then my wife was doing late night last night and then I'm on the road with
Louie and uh,
you know,
he's this,
I have a lot of,
uh,
my biggest fears are being like,
you know,
you've disliked and wanting to be please people.
I'm a people pleaser,
as many alcoholics are.
So I feel like,
uh,
you feel like you're in the fire and these controversial situations in the
bigger audience,
the more people who are breaking down what you're saying and being like,
what's up with this fucking guy?
What is it like doing the road with you doing the road with Louis now?
Yeah.
Uh,
well we've done a few dates.
I've done a few dates with them.
Um,
it's great as the protest died down and there was,
we just did a acne Minneapolis,
I think that Max out at eight people outside.
Um,
so,
but for the most part was like four or five.
Did you say hi to them?
No,
I just walked by.
I mean,
I respect them for doing their whatever they're doing.
Um,
but guided.
Yeah.
You know what?
I was really angry and I was really angry at comedians response to his leak set.
That was very angry about that.
Yeah.
It was strange,
but I think people get pulled up into this thing for some reason.
There's a thing now where everyone thinks they're supposed to have a take on
every thing.
Exactly.
No matter what happens,
they're like,
I better come up with a tweet or my take or anything.
Not actually necessary.
People ask you,
you,
why don't you have a take on this?
Why haven't you tweeted about this?
Right.
Like,
um,
there was a,
the,
the Christ church massacre happened and uh,
I was reading about it and I was like,
God damn,
this is
fucking crazy and I'm reading about this and this guy was a,
a white nationalist and he said hi to Pooty pie before he went and killed all
these people.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Like what is this?
Yeah.
And then I never check my mentions and then I just was,
cause I was on Twitter looking at all this stuff.
[inaudible] I saw something that led to something that someone tagged me and
then I looked at my mentions for a second and like,
how can we not talk about Christ church?
You racist piece of shit.
But
I get it just happened and I don't have a take.
Like what the fuck am I supposed to say?
Rest in peace.
Like what is,
what does anyone want you to say when a massacre happens,
this was horrible.
Everybody knows it's horrible.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing now if you don't denounce something young people,
you're like done,
you're on your board supporting it.
Yeah.
And you're like,
I'm just trying to,
well,
with me,
there's been situations with just talking to people,
like they don't want you talking to certain people because those people are
right wing or those people.
And if,
oh,
you must be secretly white.
Right wing,
right.
I'm not,
I tell you,
I'm not like,
why don't you believe me?
It's a weird thing.
Like I'm a,
I'm a liberal guy who's call myself a nineties liberal,
held them up for everything.
Went sideways.
Yeah.
I'm not like a whatever is happening.
I'm a,
you know.
Yeah.
Alyssa Milano is calling for a sex strike.
Yeah,
I saw that.
I like,
that's good work.
Good luck.
Well that's what you do and no one's who fuck you anymore.
You can start saying crazy shit.
Like want to have a tech?
You guys have a sex strike ladies,
you're going to hold out like that.
And Tim Pool had the best take on that.
He's saying,
so men who agree with you won't get laid.
Right?
Like what?
That doesn't even make any sense.
Like,
but the idea that it's,
it's the same thing we're talking about earlier.
They,
they've lumped men into this category.
Like women are going to go on strike until we respect their reproductive rights
in Georgia.
First of all,
it's just Georgia.
He wants to try it for the whole country.
That's not going to help Georgia.
I don't know if you understand voting,
but that's not how it works.
There's state politics,
local politics.
Second of all,
like most men don't have anything to do with this.
It's not like we have men meetings where we get together and say,
Hey,
we've got to stop these women from Deb,
Debbie exercising their reproductive rights.
So like you're punishing a bunch of people that have nothing to do with this
because we also have penises.
Like what?
What,
what's the thought process there?
This is so,
but it's such an obvious virtue signal.
It's so obvious that this is like pussy hats and the women's mind.
We're going to do this,
I'm going to do this and the way we're going to,
we've got a sex strike and bought a bunch of her friends probably like,
yeah,
this is gonna work.
Like this is not how to handle things.
It's not us.
I've never voted against women's reproductive rights.
Right.
So if you're telling like my wife,
she can't fuck me because if she does,
she's not down for the cause.
Like wait,
you're orchestrating everyone's sex life.
That's crazy.
It's just going to make people angry at you.
It's a little strange.
And I'm like,
is that guy's,
that guy's an asshole.
Can I still get laid?
Yeah.
Not like he stinks now you can't.
And the,
you know,
abortion such a fucking creepy subject too because it's such a minefield.
Like if you're a man and you even talk about it,
I like,
first of all,
why are you talking about it has nothing to do with you.
It's a woman's right to choose and a woman's body like,
okay,
I get it.
Yes.
But it's a thing.
So if it's a thing,
you're allowed to talk about a thing,
right?
And this thing happens to be a fetus that could become a Joe list or a Jamie
Vernon or Joe Rogan or who the,
is it going to be a person?
If it keeps going,
me Vernon,
that guy right there.
Oh,
hey Jay young Jamie.
So that if as the feed is grow will become a person.
Now I'm not saying you shouldn't be able to terminate the pregnancy.
I'm not saying that,
but that is what it is.
It is.
It's going to be a person and to pretend anything else,
it's like they don't,
no one wants you to discuss it that way.
Like no one wants you to say that this is a viable offspring.
It's going to be a person someday.
No one wants you to say that.
It's just,
there's code words like a woman's right to choose.
There's like these,
these ways of describing it,
which I agree with.
I'm,
I'm not a pro life person.
I'm pro choice person.
Right?
But when it gets to be like five months old and then people are saying,
well that's just a woman's right to choose.
Okay,
okay.
It is,
it is.
but that's a baby now.
But that thing could live outside the womb,
but isn't there?
Um,
isn't that law?
And I'm,
I don't,
I haven't read that,
but Georgia law,
but it isn't,
I don't know the Georgia law,
but like this thing with now they can late Tang term.
Isn't that specifically if the baby or mother is in danger?
No,
no,
not everywhere.
Um,
in some places it is.
In some places it's not some place you just have the right to have an abortion
up until a certain amount of time.
And I think it varies.
I don't think there's a federal guidelines.
I think that's one of the reasons why Georgia just instituted this six week
thing.
Like their thing is the moment that child is a heartbreak,
the heartbeat.
And that apparently is six weeks in.
Sometimes people don't even find out they're pregnant until seven,
eight,
nine weeks in.
And then you're saying they have to carry the baby.
Yeah.
It's a fucking minefield.
It's a hard,
and I like many subjects,
uh,
people want it to be just kind of black and white.
Yeah.
Well we need to have a sex strike to suit this out.
That's what it is.
Girls.
We're going to go on the sex track.
How many women read that and we're like,
yeah,
none.
I'm on CRM at a maybe,
maybe a few thousand,
few crazy bitches just out of their fee and a few men like,
yes,
please take it away from me.
Please let me show my picture.
I'm going to show him.
I have our true,
yeah,
I imagine it's a small amount.
Imagine being her husband.
She's like,
we're going on a sex strike.
That's it.
Sex Strike.
And she sees the fucking,
the Twitter post and she made a poster for it.
Like with the little fucking pink ribbon in Shit and like good Christ.
He's probably like it just,
he's probably talking to his lawyer like what?
Okay,
what would I lose it?
Okay.
If we left,
if I left right now,
like how much would have to pay?
Like what if she can test that.
Okay.
And then how much of the legal fees or how many,
what is it like an average amount of time you have to spend in court?
It's all men.
They all did it.
No sex for any man until we get our right.
Well,
it's a very similar,
I mean,
isn't that the mindset of a racism?
Yes.
That's a very similar mindset of like,
oh,
someone was murdered or these,
you know,
six guys and the train were yelling at me.
Exactly.
No more Latinos on the train.
Yeah,
100%.
Yeah.
It's the same things,
generalizations and the idea that you have anything to do with other males and
it's even crazier than racism because it's like the whole gender,
it's the whole gender.
It's like not,
not just like just white guys suck.
No.
It's like fucking everybody sucks.
Nobody gets any pussy right.
For,
until we sort this out.
Yeah.
But I,
but do you think maybe a part of it is just that,
what is it,
Jamie?
Oh,
this is Bridget,
my friend Bridget fantasy until it,
the mulattoes husband to call me.
But you know what's funny is I liked it.
Yeah.
She
liked it.
Alyssa Milano liked it.
That's a good joke.
She's gotten,
it is,
she's funny.
Bridget fatus.
He is very funny.
Um,
but she's got to know that was ridiculous thing to say.
Sometimes you swing and you miss.
Just like sometimes you have a joke that you try out and it bombs
and just said,
well,
fuck this joke.
Yeah.
I've been on jokes where I'm like,
oh no one even realized an attempt at humor had just been.
Those are where you're like,
oh sorry.
No,
it's weird when a line kills at one show and then dies at the next show.
I swear that's the same joke.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Sometimes bits just work for like weeks and then they go away and then they stop
and you're like,
what the fuck happened here?
I think it's your enthusiasm for them.
Yeah.
I think that's part of part of it.
Yeah,
and it feels more fresh at the beginning and yeah,
you start faking.
The funk in the crowd starts to smell it.
You don't give a fuck about the subject.
They can smell it on me.
What movies?
This,
they can smell it on me.
Share as that dog can smell it.
I don't remember anybody.
What is that?
That was a Tim Roth in reservoir dogs.
Oh really?
I do one impression and it's Tim Roth and reservoir dogs and it's not even
great.
Fuck you.
Cause he's got British,
but he's doing an American accent.
So sometimes it kind of sounds weird.
[inaudible] they can smell it on me.
That's what he's in the,
um,
the drug deal.
Oh yeah.
Tell that story.
That was a good fucking movie.
I love that movie.
I met Quentin Tarantino.
He's an odd fellow.
He's a wonderful artist.
But yeah,
he's still a little bizarre.
It's very odd.
But he's a fantastic director,
but he had all bombshell with them.
I was like to be,
oh,
the woman is what that guy looks like to be with,
with her.
Like,
whew.
Boy Did you figure it out?
Okay.
I'm not good at impressions.
I'm really bad at impressions.
So will you pissed off when that,
uh,
Lucy Kay,
recording got released in comics were denouncing it?
Yeah,
it was weird.
I mean,
it's a bummer of a few.
First of all,
people,
a lot of people were like,
these aren't even jokes.
He's not even joking anymore.
And you're like,
no,
no.
They're jokes.
Like,
I understand if you're,
um,
don't like it or you're offended,
but you're like,
they're definitely jokes.
He's onstage.
He doesn't really think that they threw a fat kid in front of them and rent.
That's not how he feels.
He's saying something that's fucked up and funny.
And it's funny because it's fucked up because you're not supposed to say it,
which is the exact thing he's done his whole career.
Right.
And it's a new bed.
It wasn't supposed to be heard outside of this done.
And for these people,
there's a lot of times you'll say something one way and then you're like,
ah,
it's not working.
And then you'll figure out another way to sneak in through the back door.
It works way better.
And then if they heard the first way and like this joke sucks.
Like,
no,
I figured out how to say it later.
But now it's already on youtube.
You've ruined the material.
Yeah.
I mean he dropped the bit.
Um,
cause it's just kinda like,
yeah,
it's out there too much.
But,
uh,
I had a fucking hilarious line.
If you're wanting people to forget about you jerking off,
make jokes about kids getting shot.
Yeah.
He
does.
Also funny line where he's like,
why are you in a suit?
Which is funny.
Um,
but yeah,
and then people were talking about how,
um,
now the parents have to hear this and stuff and you're like,
well,
they weren't going to,
you took it and put it out and then CBS picked it up and put it on CBS.
So now they're hearing it.
But before that there was just 180 people on long island hearing it.
Mm.
Yeah.
Which is what it was supposed to be.
But the thing about working on material is if you like comedy,
you can't release people shit like that because you're never going to get good
comedy because everyone's getting,
like every time Dave Chappelle does,
uh,
you know,
workout set or anybody,
you're gonna get these half cooked bits and then you're gonna to release them
and it's going to ruin it for you.
It's going to ruin it for you,
for the people that listen.
It's like for the people that are in the room,
that's for them,
right?
If you're taking it out,
and there's been a lot of talk about Louie making this copyright thing,
saying that you know that there was a legal action if you print or you do
anything to record or do anything to put the material online and someone saying
he can't do that.
I'm like,
well,
why can't he do that?
The deal with the difference between that and music.
Like if you go to hear someone sing a song and you write down the lyrics and go,
oh my God,
uh,
Gary Clark Jr has this amazing new song.
Here's the lyrics.
That doesn't ruin the song.
Right?
But if you say,
oh,
he's got this hilarious joke and the twist is he says this,
well,
you just fucked that bit up for everyone that's ever going to listen to,
to read that,
right?
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it's frustrating.
It was a frustration,
but then people start being like,
he's all right now.
He's going to do it.
He was like,
no,
he's not.
People are God damn crazy.
Uh,
but the comedians that denounced it were embarrassing.
It's like,
do you not know what a workout set is?
Do you understand this guy was out of comedy for almost a year.
Do you know that this guy was doing a fucking hour after being out a commie for
almost a year?
Fuck you full stop pretending that what you do is different.
Stop in.
So many people were doing it and it turned out that they had a bunch of jokes
that were awful or about a mass shooting or about pulling your dick out in front
of someone or about anything along those lines.
It's also a bad precedent to start where I'm like,
do we really want to start publicly shitting on comics?
Unfinished bits.
Exactly.
That seems like cause I don't want that.
No.
I suppose I saw a list at a fucking seller and he's got this hack and you're
like,
oh,
give me a moment.
Tell me behind the closed doors that like my piss hacky or something.
How long is it,
you're a bit ready before like do you have a comedy central special?
You have something,
right?
Right.
Did I have a Netflix half hour and I did a comedy central half hour.
Okay.
So
how long did you have to work on those bits before you were ready to put them on
comedy central or Netflix?
Quite a while.
I like to do a bit at least three months before it's somewhere.
Yeah.
W as at the very least.
And it
depends on the bit,
right?
Some bits are pretty fucking good.
A couple of weeks in and other bits or I've got a couple of bits of my act now
I'm,
I'm like,
this mother fucker needs an overhaul and I don't even know where to start.
Yeah.
I've had bits that I did for,
I've done for two years.
And then you finally find a line,
you're like,
ah,
there we go.
That was it.
And then you're like,
now it's more of a bit,
exactly.
Cause it takes,
it takes time to figure it out.
And uh,
but yeah,
it's comics should,
but I understand people,
people hate Lou and they're going to hate them.
And so whatever he does or says they're going to believe,
believe it.
You know what?
I think a lot of it is,
I think people are justifiably upset at the idea of him jerking off in front of
women that didn't want him to.
Here's,
there's a couple factors that though,
one is that he asked,
you know,
yeah,
it's a weird thing to want to do,
jerk off in front of people,
but he asked and a lot of these stories,
the way you're getting the version of it,
it's like worst case scenario,
it's like he blocked the door,
he didn't block any doors,
you know,
and they were laughing like people were joking around like it became this
traumatic thing years later talking about it after the fact.
But then on top of that,
it's like,
God,
don't you think the guy has suffered enough?
Like when,
when is he suffering enough?
You see this lack of empathy with people where they don't even want to respect
that he's a human being.
They don't,
they don't want to appreciate any of his old work.
They don't want,
they don't have anything that he could do that would make them just go,
all right,
well I know you're not going to do that again.
And uh,
you seem like a reasonable person.
It's like we look,
you can't be your past.
You're not the guy who shitting that sneaker,
right?
You're Joe list today.
Yeah.
Right.
Nobody wants to be remembered for the worst thing they did.
It's,
and it's,
I think it's just a thing where they know it's an easy target.
I really do.
I think at a certain point in time people just decide that this is a guy that
you can take a free shot at and you can shit on him and you can attribute things
to him that aren't true.
You can attribute,
attribute a bunch of things to him that are not accurate and it's easy like,
like calling them outright or saying Lucy Kay,
showing his true colors.
Now Jesus Christ,
go back and watch his bit about hitting a deer.
Okay.
It's a fucking ridiculous,
really funny material.
And that's what I enjoyed about his act,
this,
that,
that bit if left alone,
I mean it's an out of his act now,
but if left alone in x amount of time,
he would have crafted that into a great bit,
I'm sure of it.
Yeah,
I agree.
And there was,
so there was a bunch of Shitty fucking halfass comics that came out and were
talking trash about it and I was like,
you guys should shut the fuck up because this,
this whole art form is about trial and error.
This whole art form is about being able to war.
It's one of the rare things that we need a crowd to in order to,
for these things to come alive.
We need it and you have to take chances.
I just thought,
ironically with Louie,
I wait,
we went and saw apocalypse now during the Tribeca film festival and a Francis
Ford Coppola there.
And he came out and he spoke about the film beforehand and after.
And Robert Duvall was also there and he came out and went,
Charlie don't surf.
It was amazing and it was really unbelievable.
But a couple of was talking after the film and he was like,
I don't have,
you know,
the whole story about apocalypse now,
that documentary hearts of darkness,
which is amazing.
And like he put like his house up for sale to like put everything on the line to
make the movie himself.
And he was just talking about you have to take chances with art.
He's like,
there's no art without taking big chances.
And,
uh,
I mean that's,
you're taking a chance by doing a joke.
I mean,
I wouldn't do a joke about,
uh,
parkland shooting by wouldn't either,
but um,
but you know,
it's a,
it's a risk and it might go bad and it went well.
He got laughs,
got laughs.
Um,
but certainly if you take anything outside of,
um,
a comedy,
comedy club,
we put it out in the public.
It's not for those people,
for the people that bought the ticket.
Well,
it's also in context of the experience of being in a comedy club,
having a couple drinks of watching a hilarious guy talk some shit.
Especially a guy coming back after a national scandal worldwide.
Worldwide scandal.
Yes.
You know,
and it's just,
look,
I wouldn't joke around about them getting shot either,
but one of the things that made that bit work was that yes,
it was a horrible tragedy.
Yes.
Those kids went through that.
Yes,
they're teenagers.
Yes.
They're trying to figure out life and they're being interviewed on CNN and some
of them were changing their opinions and they're developing and growing as we
speak,
but like one of them,
like the David Hogg Guy broke fuck the Patriarchy on his Twitter the other day.
Like that was his tweet like,
and not even as a joke,
like that's an 18 year old.
That's what kids do.
They say silly shit.
That's why the bit worked.
Right.
He was like,
why are you interesting,
right?
I'm like,
why do I have to hear from you?
But well you have to hear from them because their friends got shot.
I mean,
but no one obviously like that's not it.
This is not a conversation.
This is stand up comedy.
It's an art form and saying things that are funny that are fucked up,
that's part of the art form.
And if you deny that just either that's not the kind of comedy you like or you
don't appreciate what comedy is.
Yeah,
and also it's a weird thing where I'm like,
I'm for those kids.
I'm like,
yeah,
it's great.
Like this horrible thing happened and you're like,
we're going to use what power we have.
I'm like,
I think that's great.
Yes.
And they might actually fucking do something.
I mean it's like they're making changes and I'm like,
Eh.
It's like fucking power to the people.
God bless you.
But I can still laugh at a joke about it.
It's still funny to me to see someone be like,
why are you in a suit?
You can both things can exist.
You can have empathy for murder victims and even be like rude and be like,
wow,
that's amazing what these kids are doing or these still people at job and still
be like,
ah.
It's funny.
It's not as best joke,
but this wasn't done.
You fucks.
And here's the other thing,
like,
do you know Brian Holtzman is?
I don't think so.
Got to see him when you're in town if you can.
He's fucking hilarious.
He's legitimate maniac.
He's a legend in Los Angeles.
Started when I started the comedy store in [inaudible] 94 he was already there
and really fucking funny.
But he had it.
You remember when Susan Smith drowned her kids at lady,
she pushed her fucking car into the river or something and drown her kids.
No,
but it sounds like he was on stage a very short amount of time afterwards going,
ladies,
gentlemen,
I heard those were bad kids.
He goes,
I heard they sat that close to the TV.
They never put away that blocks.
They always spilling the fucking milk was those kids will not be missed.
Yeah.
Had you were just like,
why it's not,
he didn't really think those are
bad kids.
It's a fucked up thing to say.
That happens to be funny.
Yeah.
You might not be into that kind of humor.
That's okay.
Well.
That's part of,
I think what comedy is or has always been,
is saying a thing you're not supposed to say.
That's like,
to me the very idea of comedy.
Yes.
Is you're saying abnormal things like you talking about coming in your own face
and whatever,
or someone coming in your friends.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to express your sexual desires so openly.
It's not that you really mean that.
I do not so funny.
Right,
right.
I think so
can be funny.
It's an art form that is often cited or quoted as if it's a statement,
you know,
like he said this like yet needed.
He said that on stage in a comedy club as a part of a big giant chunk about this
and you're taking out of context and you do it in the worst possible way.
You put it in print.
Of course it looks terrible.
Of course looks terrible in print because it's not in a comedy club and it's not
in context.
It's like that has no relationship to the actual bid itself.
Your print version of it.
It's not,
it's a lie.
You should go to jail for saying that's the joke.
You're a liar.
You're defaming someone.
You're taking what they're doing and you're pretending that what they were
saying is what they mean.
You know,
that's not what they mean.
That's,
I don't care.
Remember that,
uh,
Lenny boots and that's in the movie Lenny,
I think we talked about,
they were like reading his act.
Yes,
exactly.
You're not saying it right.
Clean.
It's the same thing.
It's,
look,
no one thinks school shootings are a good thing.
No one does.
They,
they're doing jokes about it because we know it's a horrible tragedy.
That's why jokes work and they don't,
they don't work because you're mean they don't work because you're horrible.
They work because everyone knows you're joking.
If everybody really thought you are a horrible person and you were happy that
people get shot,
they wouldn't laugh at a God damn thing.
He said,
right.
That's it's uh,
it's a fucking weird art form.
It's a weird art form.
And for it to be dismantled and disrespected the way it is where people are.
When people break down people's bits and,
and take them out of context like that,
it's,
it's so foolish and the fact that people don't stand up for it that are in the
art form itself,
that drives me fucking crazy.
It drove me angry.
These are a bunch of people that won't even talk to anymore.
I'm like,
I'm not talking to you anymore.
Like,
this is what you're going to do.
If I do a bit that's half cooked and then you're gonna talk shit about me.
Right?
Like this,
you're doing this for your own favor.
You're not doing this for the art form.
You're not doing,
you're not an empathetic person.
You know?
You don't looking at him as a human being saying,
well,
clearly the guy fucked up.
He made some mistakes.
Oh,
I bet it was okay,
but look that if you listen to that set,
that's a good set.
Especially for a guy who's been at a comedy for almost a fucking year,
it's gotten a lot stronger.
I'm sure he's a hilarious comedian.
I mean,
he's going to get to a point where he's got a real motherfucker have an hour and
then someone's going to have to figure out whether or not they're willing to
take a chance and put it on.
Well,
it's like you're talking about earlier too.
I mean,
you can also just put it on youtube.
There's website or youtube or witness.
I hope he does that.
You know,
I mean the,
it's this idea that you should be punished for eternity.
So like what do we Catholics,
like what's going on here?
Like what is this?
Did you know?
What did he do?
I mean,
he did something that caused one of crossing them $35 million.
A massive public shame.
Still to this day,
more than,
it's almost like two years later.
Was it like a year and a half now?
November,
2017 yeah.
Let me,
what the fuck?
Like what do you want them to do?
You know,
I mean,
we're not talking about Harvey Weinstein here and this idea that you're,
you know,
you're not even supposed to compare offenders.
You know,
you're not supposed to make judgment calls.
Well of course you are.
That's why some people go to jail for life and some people go to jail for two
years.
And this is,
this is the reason why we have lessor punishments for lesser crimes.
There's a system.
Yeah,
please.
If you ask people,
if you can jerk off in front of him and they say no,
and you don't check off in front of them,
good for you.
You've got some restraint.
If you ask people if you can jerk off in front of it and they say yes and you do
it,
look,
maybe it's a weird thing to do,
but you're,
you're not bill Cosby okay.
To say that you're not supposed to make these comparisons and be like,
this is a loaded subject too,
right.
We were talking about this and I see you're nervous.
Oh yeah.
I'm terrified.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
I love Louie.
I love Louie too.
He's a great comic.
Yeah.
He's a great guy also.
But yeah,
I understand.
People are upset.
I get it,
I get it.
But I think it's disproportionate.
I really do.
You know,
I have a degree.
Agree wholeheartedly.
But yeah.
Um,
how long do you think it's going to be before people just let it go?
Well,
I think,
I think there's actually,
um,
the group of people that are really upset about it.
I think it's probably like a quarter of a million people.
That's a lot of people.
It's a lot of people,
but there's like 300 million people in the country.
Maybe it's less than a quarter of a million.
It's,
I thought,
I think it's the minority.
So you think most people like,
ah,
he did something crazy.
But the other thing is like,
you want to kind of see the guy that jerked off in front of women,
so people want to go see him.
I mean,
he's a great comic stuff,
but I mean the shows,
I mean
I,
I'll read Twitter and stuff.
I sometimes I'll go on to got,
we'll hang out and I'll just search his name to see.
Like one time we went out to eat in New York and there was a kid,
you know,
like a hipstery.
It looks similar to me actually.
Um,
but like a young kid and he stopped and just like stared at us and was like I,
they started taking photos and then he left and then I looked up Louise name on
Twitter and I found the kid and he wrote just all caps.
Just gave Louis the finger,
which he didn't,
didn't give us the liquor areas.
And then he wrote,
she's signaling and then he wrote attention.
Nyu students,
there's all caps.
Louis Ck is in the neighborhood.
Make him uncomfortable.
Exclamation point.
We were like,
that's like psychotic.
You're a,
but that's what I was talking
come on earlier that I think he's a target.
I think they just decided that this is what they're going to do now.
Like that guy was saying that he gave me the finger when he did and that's the
virtue signaling aspect of it is one of the weirdest parts about social media
because it's people that ordinarily,
like in a,
in a real world scenario,
you have an opportunity to say something if you really feel so compelled to guys
right in front of you,
you don't say shit.
And then you get online and tell other people to do it right.
Other people to make them uncomfortable.
Well,
for the most part,
yeah,
we'll,
we'll go around and it is,
everything is,
it's the weird thing about online,
most people are much different in person cause you realize it's a human being.
I think the natural thing is like,
oh,
this is a person.
Exactly.
And then,
you know,
we'll go to like these kinds of hipstery coffee shops where you think that that
kind of person would be.
And he goes,
hi,
how are you?
Can I get a,
uh,
cotton?
They go,
oh sure.
Yeah,
that nobody,
I mean,
people would get dirty looks and stuff here on their books.
Well that's way more online than,
than not online.
But that's a shows.
All the shows are all selling out and there's a few people outside.
Um,
has he ever talked to those people outside or does he just get in?
No,
I don't think so.
How does he get in this kind of a backdoor?
We just went in the back and,
um,
you know,
good for them.
I think that they're misguided.
Like you said,
but yeah,
I,
I think they want him to be this evil person they should be protesting against.
But I think if you look at it on paper,
what he did was just not good.
It's like,
it's,
you know,
the worst that I had heard was that some people's careers it suffered because
they were talking about it right.
At someone.
But I don't know how much of that is accurate.
I know.
I,
I'd need to find out about that.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't know either.
I don't know the whole thing,
but I always feel like I love Louis.
He's one of my best friends now.
Uh,
which is weird to say,
but,
uh,
we're close.
But I don't really begrudge the women,
I think that two different people can have the same experience and take
different things from it feel different ways.
That's true.
And I understand.
Um,
sexuality is weird.
So like they could in the moment and his perception might be where they said
yes.
And I think he kind of talks about this a little bit on state and I don't want
to tell his feelings,
different stories to tell,
but I think one person can be like,
I thought they were into it.
I thought they were saying yes and they're into it and those women can say,
can feel,
yeah,
we kind of said
yes,
but we felt fucked up and pressured to people can have the same experience and
have different perspectives.
So I don't of course,
but grudge any of the women I understand that they are um,
hurt and feel mistreated that say yes,
you're still,
and you see something you didn't want to see like whoa.
And then you can never unsee it.
Yeah.
It's like it's in your head.
Yeah,
I understand they're affected by it,
but um,
jerk off in front of,
you know,
I keep asking,
I'll do it.
No,
no.
I asked him to come [inaudible] to ask first.
Maybe that's his thing.
Bob,
maybe I initially I blew it.
Maybe you have to like pretty shy.
Yeah.
It's like,
you know what I would hate if you jerked off in front of me.
So like drop pins.
Yeah.
Maybe I will.
But he's a,
but he's a,
he's a,
he's a good person and I'm a great dad and I,
I love him.
I love the guy.
Yeah.
Everybody wants to erase everything he's ever done.
It's so like they'll didn't FX,
like not just cancel it,
but they made the show unavailable.
Yeah.
I think you can get on iTunes,
but yeah,
it's done.
And then,
um,
I think he's still on Netflix though.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
You could still see,
but they canceled the new one that he was gonna do.
And then pets too.
Uh,
they tried,
they got rid of them.
Yeah.
So it was a,
it was a bummer,
but it's weird.
But people,
I mean,
shouldn't we be empathetic to all people?
Yes.
I think we should.
And I think,
you know,
maybe it would serve him if he went out and talked about it extensively,
like had a conversation about like maybe videotaped it or something.
I don't know if people had his take on it other than that little letter that he
wrote right after adapting.
Yeah.
Maybe that would help.
Which I thought was a good,
um,
apologetic,
good statement.
I thought,
yeah,
some people will never be happy and some people were happy with it and some
people just felt like it wasn't enough that,
you know,
he didn't specifically say,
I am sorry.
You know,
I feel horrible.
I'm sorry I did this.
He basically said he did it and those stories are true and that he fucked up and
he thought that they,
you know,
he thought that by them saying yes,
that that was okay.
But meanwhile he took advantage of the fact they admired him.
Yeah.
And he's very,
yeah,
he expressed regret.
People are like,
but like you said,
just going,
people are going to be unhappy no matter no matter what.
No matter what.
Even if he said,
I am sorry,
that's not good enough.
You're only sorry cause you got caught.
Like people,
they're always going to have,
there's some people that are just not empathetic.
And,
um,
this is what I really got very angry about with the,
the,
the leak of the recording.
I'm like,
yeah,
it's not as best material.
Of course it's not,
he hasn't done comedy in 10 months.
Like when I was hearing it from other Comedians,
I'm like,
do you,
how do you,
how do you do this?
Right.
Don't you do the same thing we do?
Like what are you doing?
He's a fucking person.
He's a human being.
He's a year and a half of him being stared at everywhere he goes.
Yeah.
And fucked with he gets it and losing friends.
Yes.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
But he,
those friends,
if he lost some friends,
he's better off if he lost friends because of that.
Like if that was Ari,
I would call them up.
Like if there was a New York Times article about Ari jerking off in front of
people,
I be like,
Bro,
I'm a little hurt.
You never jerked off in front of me.
Like I feel like I wouldn't,
I would if he's like,
I fucked up.
Like,
I've had conversations with Ari about things where,
you know,
he's like,
oh,
I fucked up.
I shouldn't have done that.
It was a bitch move.
Like he'll tell you.
Yeah.
You know,
like you can't do anything once you're my friend.
Like let's hear out there murdering kids or something or doing something really
fucked up or actually raping someone.
Any friends that Louie loss for that,
like,
come on man.
What did you think?
Did you think it was a perfect person?
He's a nut.
He's a maniac.
Goddamn professional comedian.
Right,
right.
You know?
Yeah.
We're flawed people.
That's how it all comes out.
Good.
It's like there's gotta be something fucked up about your head where you can
come up with these.
And the another one that drives me crazy is these guys who,
you know are freaks and they're out of their fucking mind offstage,
but onstage,
they have like sort of a more squeaky clean thing and their public thing is more
squeaky clean and they're judgemental about it and like,
oh my God,
like please stop.
You're fucking crazy as anybody.
You just have a good squeaky clean act.
So shut your hole.
Yeah.
Sometimes I think the people with the cleanest acts of the wildest animals,
it's often the case.
Yeah.
It's often the case.
Which is fine man.
Like perfect example is Brian Regan in a good way.
He is so fucking funny and so clean.
The funniest you go.
This guy's gotta be fucked up.
There's gotta be something wrong with you.
Nothing.
Hang out with them.
Super normal friendly guy.
Nice to everybody.
Great Guy.
The nicest guy.
Why is in your dungeon,
sir?
What time?
We were hanging out and he was smoking a cigar and I thought it'd be funny to
say,
Hey,
can I get a little bit of that Ciga?
Cause it's such a ridiculous,
and he was like,
oh sure.
And I was like,
what?
No,
I'm kidding.
I wouldn't put my mouth on yours.
The car.
But you didn't want to do with the joint,
which I thought was strange too.
And a blunt.
You do it with a blunt,
which is kind of half joking,
half cigar.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Actually I'm the asshole in this story.
Maybe he's not even that Nice.
That's just a normal,
no,
that is a weird thing to ask a cigar feels very personal to too.
And you're like,
it's yours for like an hour.
Exactly.
It's just kind of a quick,
well,
yeah,
joints to hits.
Like if you have a whole joint yourself,
you're greedy.
Yeah.
There's also,
there's like a camaraderie thing that comes from smoking joints together.
Yeah.
I'll do it.
I'm back.
Ready?
I've got some right here.
It's all over the place.
This is all filled with,
we'd see that chest over there.
That's a full chest filled with weed.
Wow.
Isn't that a,
can you get in trouble for that?
No,
it's legal,
but with that much,
couldn't they get you for intent to distribute or something?
No,
it's legal here.
Really?
You can just the case.
Yeah.
Marijuana is legal,
but like guns are illegal,
but that guy had a thousand.
They guy had illegal
sales.
He was selling.
I gotcha.
I see.
They got tipped off that he was a dealer.
He's probably selling it to gang members and drug dealers and such.
Oh No.
Oh by [inaudible] do you think about having just a little weed,
just a little,
just a little touch touch,
but would you just go start shooting heroin like immediately?
I don't think I would do that,
but I don't,
uh,
I don't think weed does not as much,
um,
excite me or anything.
What does drinking?
Yeah,
I mean I love Drake shot drink.
I mean,
uh,
I drank,
I mean I still,
I joke about it like I love,
uh,
my sobriety but like one and a half Vicodin and three beer was like the best
I've ever felt in my life.
Yeah.
And like a cigar.
What time I went to Baghdad?
I did like a USO thing with they park Etsy.
Um,
and uh,
we had like,
we bought Cubans and I had some bike.
I took like a Vicodin.
I don't know if he did.
I don't want to,
I don't think he did a,
but I had like a Vicodin and we had a couple beers and a cigarette.
We were at Saddam Hussein's palace in the moment.
I was like,
this is the best I've ever felt.
Did you do stand up over there?
Yeah.
What is it like doing stand up for the troops over there?
It was fine.
It was amazing.
I was the most grateful audience there was like so nice and kind and uh,
it was really cool.
I mean some of it suck cause some of it was like two in the afternoon and uh,
there's like 12 guys.
It's fucking 100 degrees.
They're holding rifles being like,
what the fuck is this?
That was the show.
A couple of them.
Yeah.
Some of them,
some of them were like the ones in Kuwait or better cause that was like not a
war zone.
Um,
and you're on a base and they be like a hundred people,
but some of them were like just in the middle of like 11 o'clock in the morning
in the middle of fucking Baghdad.
Wow.
Uh,
but it was pretty amazing.
Like we got to a fly on these black hawks and we were in Baghdad.
We went by the,
those cross swords and stuff where uh,
the statute was pulled down and shit.
What did you do when you were in Saddam Hussein's palace?
That became like an American base.
We stayed there.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's kind of stayed in Saddam Hussein's palace.
It's pretty true.
Profits on the same spot.
I don't think I did.
I think Nate and I shared a room and uh,
I asked and he said no,
I would have to,
uh,
I think I'd feel compelled.
I'd be like,
Bro,
you're going to have to leave the room.
I got a,
I got a goal.
I got to check something off the list.
It's,
it's a bizarre feeling because,
you know,
we'd like,
it was like,
um,
yeah,
we took over and then just made this palace into him pace and it's like a
driving range.
She can like hit until like his prayer pond or whatever.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Like reflection pool.
You got pray upon fill with golf balls.
Yeah.
That's lately.
And they sell Cubans in like the lobby America.
Yeah.
Where some where we're particularly our fucking something.
Um,
but no,
it was amazing.
It was awesome.
One time we were on the Black Hawk helicopter.
They shoot flares out for whatever.
I can't remember why on every flight,
but they didn't tell us that.
So all of a sudden you just hear like,
and you feel the heat.
And I thought we were in a fucking battle.
Like I almost shit my,
like it felt like,
you know,
when you don't have to shit and all of a sudden you're like,
this is shit I could shit right now.
It was that feeling your body tries to evacuate anything in there because it
thinks it's in danger.
Yeah.
So like with Spiel,
want to be able to run with.
Yeah.
When you get really nervous like that,
you immediately have to piss and shit.
Yeah.
I just took a huge hit right before this show.
Did you use the,
uh,
the little buttons on the toilet that shoot water up your asshole?
It wasn't here.
I was afraid you'd beat me up if I shit.
So it was that the Starbuck who did do that?
James Brown.
When you,
that's one of the ways he got arrested.
He shot at someone who,
uh,
uses toilet.
Oh Wow.
Shoot out with the cops.
And I wish there's a picture of him,
his mugshot right out there,
and it was from that arrest.
Wow.
Yeah.
I should,
at Starbucks,
I was at the Starbucks across the street by the way,
and homeless cooties.
I was in line and like,
uh,
a dude,
a white dude with a skateboard just cut in front of me in the lines.
Very bizarre.
And I said,
what I'm in,
I'm in the,
I'm next.
And he's like,
can I just buy some gum?
He was buying Starbucks gum,
which is already a red flag.
And I was like,
I guess,
I mean,
it was in la.
He's like,
um,
I didn't even work in five minutes.
Wow.
What a Dick.
I didn't know you could do that.
You can't do that.
I was like,
all right.
I don't have to be anyway.
Talk to you like that.
That was early.
But yeah,
he looked at me like I was an asshole.
He's a Dick.
And I was like,
maybe you shouldn't be buying gum.
Awesome.
Maybe you might want to find a different means of transportation than a
skateboard.
Yeah.
You late.
Fuck.
Yeah.
You fucking late loser.
I'm going to be at work in five minutes and I need gum.
What do you do?
Do you talk close for a living?
Yeah.
You fucking jerk if you're listing off.
He probably listened to.
He doesn't Mcdonald's.
He didn't know where I was going.
Didn't know.
He's probably like,
I'm so sorry bro.
I didn't want to get knocked at work.
We gonna get in trouble man.
Yeah,
I hate that was the last time you had a job?
Um,
2007 which do,
I worked at Sears.
I did loss prevention.
It was amazing.
It was one of the best day jobs ever.
Really?
Well my cousin was the boss,
which helped and he let me work from 10 to six,
which is great comedy hours.
And then we were like playing closed,
I guess.
Just uh,
oh,
so you just walked around and busted people stealing?
Yeah,
it had like a little radio on the,
uh,
the belt.
And then we had a crazy camera system for 2007 like it was at like,
I think we had 82 cameras and you could zoom and shit.
And you just watch people the whole day,
and then you'd walk around the store and be like,
we've got,
have to keep an eye on the camera.
11.
Let's see,
like a secret agent.
It was fun.
It was really fun.
And we got to stop shop lifters and shit.
It was amazing.
I miss,
I actually miss it.
It was really fun.
I used to work for a private investigator and a similar,
yeah,
it was,
it actually turned out,
it was one of those people where you meet and you go,
this guy should be comedian.
He was hilarious.
His name's Dave Dolan.
He's dead now.
And,
uh,
I keep a,
a voicemail message from him just because he was such,
he was such a character who was just such a fucking character.
And he was hilarious.
And he got a Dui and a,
they took away his license and what he really needed was not an assistant and
you needed a driver.
So I decided a good,
have a good driver's license.
So,
uh,
but I was working as an assistant and then we became friends and we bused
people,
mostly people that were stealing,
uh,
insurance money.
They were like doing things like pretending they were injured and they take
another job on the side and then we'd catch him.
We'd have to get there at like five o'clock in the morning and wait for them to
get up and go to work and then follow them,
take pictures of them and shit.
That's fun.
It was fun Gig.
Yeah,
it was fine.
It was real fun too because he was actually cousins with bill downs who was one
of the owners of the comedy connection.
Nobody downs.
That's it.
Worked for that guy.
A couple of tap me too many times.
And uh,
uh,
that was,
Dave was his cousin,
so it was like just dumb luck.
I became friends with this guy,
but from driving him around and his cousin was the god,
one of the guys that own the comedy connection.
Wow.
Yeah.
I loved working at Sears.
It was fun.
I feel like Canadians are actually good at that job because we're aware and
we're doing a lot of judging anyways.
You want you to like an audience come in and you're like,
that guy's gonna hate me.
This woman's too drunk,
that guy's fat.
And I think it's similar to a shoplifter.
He like,
something's up with this guy.
What's also
you like?
It sounds like a job that doesn't suck.
Like you can wander around.
No one's telling you what to do.
It's not like you're stuck at a fucking desk going over stupid numbers or
something you don't give a fuck about.
Yeah.
And it's low maintenance physically.
I know guys in New York that are like movers for their day job and I'm like,
you can't have a fucking manual labor job.
Like you get up and you're carrying couches.
Like you're not gonna hit an open mic at 8:00 PM is going to be exhausted.
Yeah.
But I loved it.
And having your cousins,
the boss is great.
I streaked through a series at the,
my last day.
You took your clothes off?
I,
yeah.
We decided,
well I didn't want to,
I couldn't go naked cause it's like a sex crime.
So I covered my face with a brown paper Bag and bought like a candy thong
necklace at the spark candidates on a necklace.
It's a candy Thong at Spencer's gifts.
No War that I got videos,
my fund,
my buddy just sent it to me.
I hadn't seen it in like 12 years.
It's a sex crime if you take your clothes off.
Yeah.
If you run through naked.
Hilarious.
That's a sex crime.
So I was like,
I better have no clothes on.
Which is how you are naturally when you're born,
you are walking sex crime.
I get it.
You can't have people running around naked in a storm in it.
Wait a minute,
but why not?
What is the problem from living in a society,
Joe,
if a woman walked through restore naked,
do you think she should go to jail?
I don't think she,
I should think,
I would assume she has mental problems.
I think she just likes to be naked.
If a,
if a gal
goes through a place like,
uh,
maybe you're a target and some,
some gouts I just take off her clothes and walk as far as she can through target
before they arrest her.
[inaudible] are you in support of her being arrested and taken to it
a jail and hit with a sex crime?
No,
I'm not in support of that,
but I,
there's a lot of things that rules and laws that I'm not in supportive that it
seems like it's okay if a guy gets arrested doing that.
Well,
it depends on what he's doing I suppose.
So I feel if a guy's running around naked,
if you just running and jogging flopping around inside target,
that guy's a criminal.
I don't need to see
is he hard or not?
It's a good question.
It's very interesting.
Is the harboring criminals.
Yeah.
If he's hard,
he goes straight to jail.
Well that's like a right to the electric chair with particular sexual cock.
They,
yeah,
it's electric condom.
What if he's got all his clothes on except for his cock and balls and he's just,
he's just riding out,
you know,
he's got a just coming out of the,
uh,
in,
in a rural,
in San Francisco,
like you can walk around naked.
You just can't have a hard on.
Is that true?
Really?
That's fine.
I just heard,
uh,
Brian Callan say that.
Why don't you Google that Google that we need to find out this true in New York.
I know in the park you can be naked.
I think naked.
I can walk around topless Taco.
I've seen a couple of women,
women are allowed to go topless because men used to be able to go top.
Well,
men could go topless forever,
but there was a rule that said the women couldn't.
And women are like,
well this is bullshit.
And they're right.
And I think a lot of them didn't even want to be topless.
Right?
But they were like,
well,
this is fucked up.
People telling us that our nip,
like Sarah Silverman,
Sarah Silverman just posted on Instagram of a photo of her mirror,
like her bathroom mirror.
And you can see your tits in the mirror.
She did it on purpose to like make a point.
Like why,
first of all she did it because she has great tits.
Okay.
She wanted everybody to see your grade tests.
They're pretty fantastic.
I missed it.
I'm bummed.
But also like,
why is it okay if you could see my tits?
Why is it okay to see my nipples?
But you can't see her nipples.
Like what do we babies?
I agree.
That's free.
The nipple.
I'm for it.
Instagram is really hardcore on that.
But Twitter,
you can do porn.
Yeah,
they'll have porn on fucking Twitter.
There's porn olds.
I fall porn stars.
They watch them.
Fuck.
Maybe that's important.
You think so?
Yeah.
Why not?
I got a dick.
You do have a deck.
It's right here.
Yeah,
it's nice.
Do you think that uh,
you should be arrested if you just walk around naked?
Um,
if I was making the rules,
I don't know.
It's hard because it's,
uh,
it's all on what you do with it if you'll rub it on people.
Yeah.
Yes sir.
That's walk around naked and kids kids point at you and laugh and you go,
Huh.
That's the thing.
It depends.
There should be a delt areas where you can walk around naked.
I think like a nude beach.
Yes.
They have those,
have those but arrested.
I don't know.
I would just assume someone is a little off mentally.
Exactly.
Walking around naked or are um,
societal Terry,
uh,
norms and forth since I don't think so.
That sounds like a guy.
Society Terry.
Like a horse that wins the Kentucky Derby.
It says that they changed the public nudity law and San Francisco and like 23rd,
19,
I think.
But we were there when you shot your special,
and I'm 100% I was at the top of Lombard Street and there was a large gathering
of naked people,
so I don't know what the fuck that was about nonsense.
So that was,
they didn't get it stopped.
There's cops right there.
They didn't stop him from doing anything.
I pictures of it.
So I don't know what that was about.
What are we going to do?
I've got to wrap this up,
Joe.
Last.
You're funny,
motherfucker.
Thanks for having appreciate.
Comedy is very funny.
I hope it was okay.
You were great.
And people see your Netflix special.
Uh,
it's available.
And comedy central,
they have it online too,
right?
Yeah,
it's online.
That Netflix thing is,
uh,
the standup season.
Two of the standups.
It's a half hour,
and I've got a couple of albums online and stuff.
Joe Lists would be with me tonight at the Improv.
It's sold out two shows with Bert Kreischer and Andrew motherfucking Santina.
No,
that's it folks.
Bye everybody.
Thank you.
Say Bye Jo.
Liz.
Thanks Joe.
This comedy is that you're a,
what's your Instagram?
Twitter,
comedy,
Instagram and Twitter.
All right.
Bye.